and the sentence is done
elaine maxwell will be in prison for 20
years apparently it's like a low
security thing and uh going to prison
for trafficking children to no one
apparently to not a single person but uh
apparently still trafficking trafficking
them so uh you have to wonder who we'd
love to see the uh the list of clients
but for some reason they're not telling
us also maxwell was placed on um
suicide watch sparking many memes so i
guess we're going to talk about all of
that and we also have news pertaining to
democrats because
this is hilarious for the past couple of
weeks it's been reported that democrats
have been
funding
trump supporting republican candidates
in republican primaries
under the the idea that it's going to
help them win
i don't understand what they they think
like well these these pro-life
republicans can't possibly win a general
election meanwhile people are vowing to
vote against the democrats regardless of
who they're voting for because i don't
know the economy is in shambles and the
democrats have embraced insane cultural
issues those tend to be in in the polls
people saying like hey i don't like that
like you look at virginia with yunkan
and now you look at the five dollar gas
all they're doing is propping up trump
and then holding january 6 hearings
where they complain about trump and
blame
the things they're funding for
destroying this country it's beautiful
and then the last uh we got a bunch of
other stories but one is really really
funny apparently a former white house
staffer is claiming trump lunged at the
steering wheel and tried to like
commandeer a vehicle through the
security barrier from the back seat to
the front it makes no sense the story
makes no sense trump came out and said
it's nonsense and apparently we have a
statement to journalists that they're
corroborating secret service agents who
said this lady at the january 6 hearing
is making it up
can't say i'm surprised ladies and
gentlemen before we get started with all
of that news head over to timcast.com
and become a member to help support our
work as a member you'll get access to
exclusive segments from this show monday
through thursday at 11 pm members only
it is uncensored tim cast after dark we
swear a lot and we tell naughty jokes so
you'll definitely want to check that out
and uh don't forget to smash the like
button subscribe to this channel and um
share the show if you really do like it
follow me at tim cast and follow the
show at tim cast irl joining us today to
talk about all of this is quite frankly
hey
tim who are you i come
in peace
on behalf of my tribe and so thank you
everybody for having me here that's just
one tim you know the last time i saw you
it was the day before you went to malmo
oh wow it was a lay before a while ago
the other thing there too is
tim went to a local diner with me after
one of those shows that we were hanging
out one night and you've become very
very very famous since then you've
become they've actually bronzed the seat
that you sat in that knife
yes i know it's diana ross and tim poole
when it comes to greenwich connecticut
there's nobody bigger
so so what do you do oh i'm just a talk
show host from new york current events
history hidden history actually most
hidden uh history is hidden these days
you know what i mean ian
yeah i i don't know i can't tell because
i can't see it but i think you might be
onto something well either way that's
what it is that the human condition we
just like talking about things that uh
make us human and and i'm so happy to be
here it's been a wonderful day so far
the drive was beautiful
a lot of trees yeah gorgeous out here
that's cool there's groundwater rabbits
everywhere reminds me of upstate new
york to be honest except we have wine
berries
i never see there's wild chinese
raspberry everywhere
you just like walk up the driveway and
you can fill up your hands with just all
these berries and just eat them and be
full and you're done
now they're not quite uh in bloom yet or
whatever fruiting whatever the word is
but i had a couple today just walk
around and pick them up
is it is there like a limit before the
diarrhea sets in it's like one of those
things
well i mean i'm pretty sure if you eat
anything to excess probably but they're
delicious and amazing and we made ice
cream with them last year yeah sheamus i
can see he's jealous i remember that no
i think i was here when you guys made uh
i remember you making something out of
them we want to make wine wine wine wine
wine berry wine wine berry wine wine
wine
i don't actually think we can do it but
i don't know
not without a liquor license sir that's
right i don't know
west virginia if you're gonna do that
you better stomp the berries with your
bare feet like they do in the old
country
stomp the berries do it wine
sheamus who are you well
that's a tough question it keeps me up
uh most nights and i'm not entirely sure
but i can tell you what i do i create
cartoons at a youtube channel called
freedom tunes we just released one today
i think you guys are really gonna enjoy
it it's been a hit the fans are are
loving it it's how lefty's debate it's a
short 30-second one that i think will
enrich your life we also launched a
website and on that website
we will be posting every week either a
new cartoon that week that is just
exclusive for patrons or like a a much
extended cut of the current video like
several minutes longer so go over there
freedomtunes.com become a member five
bucks a month help us get free from the
establishment and big tech well hello
everyone ian crossland here and i'm
actually thinking about what you said
frank about hidden history because when
someone's telling his story
uh it's really not only is it about the
things he tells you but also about the
things he didn't tell you and that's
what they call reading between the lines
or telling her story yeah right
are you changing language as we speak i
just think it's cool that it bothers you
that you would say herstory
do you have something i'm part of the
patron i know i'm just part of the
patriarchy the roman people let's use
roman numerals in our constitution i was
reading through the constitution last
night and the roman numerals were making
me ill all right we got to just change
them
like this
look i mean it's hard arabic numerals
only
you know oh well let's i'll talk about
this on the show let me get this out of
the way really quick you know the white
house is like those white roman pillars
i realized the romans painted their
white marble and the paint just wore off
absolutely but the americans are like
dude let's do white buildings everywhere
it's like we did paint those as well and
the paint were off okay no i'm kidding
so let's paint the white house is what i
mean we had to paint the white house
sometimes after it was burned down in
the 1812 war yeah what's a good color
purple red for the white house purple
well i think well hold on you guys whoa
you guys don't want to do pride colors
immediately i'm open to repainting you
know at will periwinkle i think
color the ukraine flat do a wrap you
know those wraps where it like it
changes color depending on how you look
at it holographic holographic wraps
you know what i think we should do i
don't know why we didn't do this after
it got burnt down the first time but
like it into the landscape camouflage
don't let anyone know where it is that's
just all sky blue exactly exactly there
you go anyway it's been a good
conversation already i was gonna say
that most of history is hidden and i see
people commenting on the news nowadays
and they're like well if this is what
they're covering up this makes you
wonder about all the rest of history so
i think that yeah probably all history
is to some degree very much hidden
anyway i'm very excited for tonight's
conversation looking forward to your
perspective for sure here's the big news
ladies and gentlemen maxwell sentenced
to 20 years in prison for what as
epstein case nears its end maxwell the
former socialite who conspired with
epstein to exploit underage girls was
sentenced to 20 years in prison on
tuesday by a judge who said she played a
pivotal role in facilitating a horrific
scheme that spanned continents and years
maxwell 60 is the daughter of a british
media magnate robert maxwell convicted
december 29th of trafficking and other
counts after a month-long trial at which
the government presented testimony and
other evidence depicting maxwell as a
sophisticated predator who groomed
vulnerable young women and girls as long
as as long as young as 14 years old for
abuse by epstein is that it
just epstein i guess
people gracious people were flying on
his plane with him and going to his
island but
it was just a coincidence
so so uh maxwell's client list is
published it's epstein that's it we're
done everybody you can go home that's
all it was nothing to see here
this article frames it as as it comes to
an end as the epstein case comes to an
end we're now laying the hammer down as
hard as we can on gee lane to show that
it's definitely done don't ask questions
well my question is do you think it's
really her
do you think it's really her like you
think actually like and actually in jail
i thought that the trial itself was such
a farce that i said to myself i wouldn't
be surprised if they say guilty they
bring her out the back door send her to
the bahamas and then just send somebody
to jail no like face off like they take
elaine and some other woman and then
like sedate her and they cut their faces
off and switch them and this other woman
is like i'm not getting i'm innocent
they're like quiet you crazy good baby
no it's her dude like i mean that's what
she said in court she used the old face
off defense like come on we've heard
that too you know how many faces i've
had the old face-off defense she has
like actual scars going around her face
and she's just and they're just like it
looks fine
no i look i'd love to believe that like
people believed that epstein wasn't
really epstein
and like they showed there's like a
picture of him being taken out of the
prison and they're like it looks
slightly different and i'm like yeah
he's dead yeah yeah like his muscles
have like
probably avoided his balls like it's
really awful stuff and i'm just like you
know i'd love to believe that they
smuggled these people out just because
it makes you think that you're actually
fighting some grand fight but come on
the reality is these people got busted
the feds backed off and we're letting
them do their thing who knows why
probably blackmail or something and then
we had a series of events we had
reporting from mike cernovich we had
reported reporting i think from the
miami herald we had reporting for
project veritas that all helped push
this into the in front and center with
maxwell and epstein and they got caught
and they got thrown to the bus and then
bill gates gets asked to ask asked about
it that was funny it's like oh what does
it matter he's dead now he's like yikes
dude you're on his plane yeah and if
they start naming names what'll happen
is they'll name one and then that person
is going to start naming a bunch of
other ones and then another and then the
whole web starts to get he just wasn't
important enough i mean i don't i don't
i never
really read into any of the it's not
really him look at the ear all that
stuff he just wasn't important enough
jeff no yeah he wasn't that's that's
somebody that's going to get flushed at
some point especially when you're when
you're in and out of the news and you
just cannot stop he was useful at a time
against again for somebody higher up the
chain
and uh and there's a lot more questions
about how high the chain
goes so you guys are ready
this is a story actually from a couple
days ago cnn reporting
elaine maxwell is on suicide watch but
isn't suicidal may need to postpone
sentencing well they didn't postpone
sentence postpone sentencing
um
but they are putting her on suicide
watch even though she isn't
and uh everybody started posting memes
because uh surprise surprise they're
like oh no she's gonna she's gonna hurt
herself and then what happened suicide
watch but not suicidal does that just
mean they're afraid someone's gonna fake
her suicide
i don't know
that's very blatant it's like a weird
thing i know
they're like she's on the watch she
doesn't want to do it
now that which is why she's on watch
she's like guys i really don't want to
commit suicide please watch me like
please look at she's not suicidal now
but she may be later yeah or let's be
real this may not be as affair as it
sounds it may be that there's a fear in
the federal government that someone
powerful is going to try and you know
flush her out what is it shake her loose
her mortal coil and so they put her on
watch
because there's no other watch that
there can be hey guys just please make
sure that the guards got a full night
rest the night before this time you know
is there a homicide watch for for uh
inmates
no because no one would ever kill an
inmate it's like unconscionable so they
don't even call it no but you're you're
by yourself right
you're you're you're in solitary you're
in a gso by yourself there's not gonna
be homicide watch they're not going to
be like because there's no one to
actually perceivably kill you yeah so
the only thing they could do to make
sure you live is put you on suicide
watch even if you're not and then they
say she's not suicidal they're basically
saying xin is saying we think somebody
wants to kill her
yeah that's what it sounds like i i mean
technically anyone could could be a
victim of homicide even if they were a
prisoner because like the guards could
be paid off to do it people on the guard
you know the prison owners could do it
what if like with epstein it was this
crazy scenario like weren't the guards
sleeping
who knows that things just happen look
i've seen i've seen x-men where you know
you have mystique
and she drugs that guy and she injects
him full of iron and then magneto
escapes so you know i'm just saying
maybe somebody drugged the guards and
then had magnetic powers to disable the
camera i remember that that proves it i
mean it's it's more believable than the
official explanation
shockingly yes that's why i don't think
that's why i don't look at this i say
how how does it end with her because she
was definitely his handler
so how does it end with her oh i i
thought for sure though there was a game
there was definitely a game of chicken
being played between her defense i mean
the whole thing was weird they brought
in the cia memory lawyers and everything
remember three lawyers yeah
there's a certain type of shrink that
comes in to talk about how your memory
was not
really what it is they try to i mean and
then of course after two weeks we got
four months of johnny depp but after two
weeks they say we got to get this over
with there's another wave of kovac
coming through new york and i this and
like you said we don't know anything you
know like the johnny depp trial while
while all this is still going on
it's just like i'm imagining
you know there's like a shocking crime
to your left and then a you know police
van opens up and a bunch of clowns come
out and start going like and they're
like dancing around everyone's like oh
hey clowns and they stopped paying
attention to the crazy crime happening
to their left indeed the bigger question
here is sure sure we know
that
you know elaine maxwell
even though we all have our suspicions
about epstein and the media is
desperately trying to be like it's a
conspiracy theory and all that but like
no sane person believes that he took his
own life
we know all this
it should probably is gonna something's
gonna happen to her and then the bigger
question is
who
who was involved
i think
nobody no yeah no one was involved at
all right i think it was bill gates
we know he flew on the plane so until
they prove otherwise it's him that's
fair
i would ask alex acosta
who's that the old trump labor secretary
who was uh who's actually part of this
whole thing when they were wrapping up
um operation leap year that actually put
the the full scope of what epstein was
doing in new mexico and florida new york
the caribbean all that together i would
ask
it was acosta was when he was getting
thrown out of of his office in 2018 or
19 or whatever the hell it was um he was
asked by somebody in the room uh how
to explain exactly who came to him to
stop the fbi from going forward with
this just the full weight coming down on
on epstein is there somebody coming up
if it was if he was uh involved with
intelligence and he said let's just he
pretty much said let's move away from
that didn't the democrats bring on the
abc news guy who shut down the the
epstein reporting to do the january 6th
trial i believe that's because that was
that what it was we need where's luke at
why isn't luke here we need him
because luke knows what's good for him
vanity fair
there's no proof of that there's no
proof of that luke and i had a
conversation and
we came to an understanding i see and
now he's gone
it's pretty florida i think i think i
didn't know if i was gonna meet luke
today i was like oh i'm gonna i might
make luke luke oh you'll meet luke i
think he's in new york he's dodged a
bullet
um i think that if you look at maria
farmer's sethiels uh painting she's
basically illustrated all the people she
remembers being involved and i'm not
going to name names because i don't want
to get into that mess messy because you
don't want to be on suicide
it's anecdotal no one knows for sure but
i have a feeling that people like you
know very very high up in government
ex-presidents maybe even did things that
they shouldn't have done with people
that were under the age of 18 and that's
why everything's completely silent
they're like about the sentence maxwell
and the judge is like do you have
anything to say for yourself before i
issue my sentencing and she goes just
love living life is great i've never
been happier i've grown quite fond of
being alive and i'd like that to be
reflected in these stenographer's notes
anyway carry on that was the funniest
part about the whole epstein thing right
before he died uh they're saying we're
putting him on suicide watch i said this
guy is not someone who wants to die he
just upped his bail uh his bail offering
to the court to like 150 million the
week before that's not something that
someone who wants to kill themselves
does that's someone who wants to get the
hell out right um and the camera stopped
working yeah guards fell asleep
here's how we're going to make sure that
nothing happens to gee lane all right
tim we're getting involved here we're
going to make elaine city and it's going
to be like chicken city but it's just
going to be cameras all over herself
yeah and if you you donate you know you
we will have guillain parties i mean
actually i don't even want to know that
oh yeah no no no what we do is there's
like a little drop from this yeah yeah
yeah corn yeah cardinal dropped this
party
and she can eat it off the ground yeah
exactly i don't know i have no respect
for this woman nothing but disdain and
so exactly and so it's just like she
gets food it'll be it'll be like uh
we'll have to make sure the quarantine's
really bad too it'll be like a
for-profit way to ensure that uh you
know she doesn't uh commit
suicide did you see oh what are you
saying i was gonna say i think they put
her on suicide watch to keep her from to
postpone her sentencing and i also
wanted to say that mccarthy did point
out that the the ex abc president who
spiked the jeffrey epstein story was in
fact in charge of the january six
hearings it'd be funny if like cute
once you raise a hundred she's like she
imagine her like in her jail cell and
people are giving five bucks and like
corn falls on the ground and she's like
she's like i'm not eating off the ground
get out of here and then a hundred
dollars gets reached and then the the
lane party happens and the lights are
flashing like corn seems like spraying
spraying corn in her face sprayed with
corn so for those that understand the
reference we have a show called chicken
city where you can do all of that for
chickens i love it and when the corn
falls in the ground it's it's actually
like treats and mealworms the chickens
love it and they run and they eat it and
they're all excited i didn't know this
until yesterday okay i didn't know i
didn't know the intro i watched you guys
as much i can't because you know my show
overlaps my second hour overlaps with
your first hour um
uh but i i was just showed yesterday the
chicken city feed
oh yeah
i didn't second most profitable show
well it literally is
i remember those chickens i remember
when epstein was in the news because he
had been arrested again and he was going
to trial this before he killed himself
and i was
talking with my uncle who was a you know
a police officer on the south side of
chicago for like 20 or 30 years
so
he had you know a more maybe more less
naive attitude than me let's say and so
i was talking i was like
yeah i'm just i'm i'm excited for this
guy to really go to trial and for some
of these people who are trafficking kids
to get exposed he goes no he's going to
kill himself he's like come on he's like
he's going to kill himself he did
they're not going to hurt the guy yeah
he didn't do the air quotes he said it
but i knew what he was saying he's like
he's like they're going to kill him he's
going to commit suicide that's it and i
was like
oh you're probably right and then three
or four days later i wake up in the
morning with the notification on my
phone jeffrey epstein has killed himself
i was like oh my goodness at this point
if they do pull off a face off with
elaine
it would be so that
they could suicide elaine without anyone
realizing it happened because if she
really does take her life
you know it's going to be just like the
at that point it's a conspiracy theory
that they killed themselves well people
are already saying about saying that
about epstein well the thing is like i
just hope no one comes into her cell
with a noose and says this is mega
country
that'd be the worst that would be the
worst i mean look at do you remember
when jesse was like i'm not suicidal
he was getting trapped out of the court
dude what that's what i'm just saying
i know it's it could be crazy but we
only get three pictures the same three
pictures of guillain maxwell over and
over again everything else is court
paintings
you just don't know and the older
somebody gets the more they look like
everybody else like when all the ruth
bader ginsburg uh rumors were going
around she literally looks like larry
king i mean you can you can you start
looking like larry king you look like a
coat rack it's just
i i think anything's anything's possible
these days i believe i can believe
anything i mean
they've certainly lost the confidence of
the people yeah and we've i think for
the most part the people have lost their
willingness to give the benefit of the
doubt when epstein's epstein's cellmate
didn't he like save him from a suicide
attempt or something like that like what
happened he got assaulted or something
right i thought he was from westchester
yeah yeah i get attacked by a cell mate
or something like that yeah and they
were like oh no like it's like dude that
guy's trying to kill him he's getting
he's getting he's getting strangled by
his cellmate and the gods are like no
epstein you have so much to live for
don't do it no don't do this to yourself
whatever
oh in the early days of jeff getting
after he got arrested i think that like
a couple weeks after he was arrested a
picture came out of him just looking
annihilated like messed up and he i
think he said that they were trying to
poison him did he say that did that come
out that does sound familiar but it
reminds me of uh that family guy episode
where quagmire is getting strangled by
his uh his sister's husband or whatever
and then he like dies
but like he just
feigns death and then the next scene is
him running over his sister's you know
his brother-in-law and he's like i
strangle myself like that every night
so like i'm just saying like epstein
getting strangled it didn't take the
first time you know like the guy tried
to hurt him and he was like ha
yeah cause they have a strong back i
have a strong neck
and then they you know his neck broke is
this so is that what happened right what
was the official narrative that he like
used toilet paper or something like i
don't i don't even know there's multiple
there's multiple breaks too
a jfk uh
uh
guy for this right what was the guy's
name
that did the autopsy
i oh that's right i know what you're
talking about i know what you're talking
about hold on let's let's get this
pulled up because i don't want to this
quote this is a refresher but i just
want to say whichever toilet paper he
hung himself with supposedly like that
toilet paper feels like they should put
that in all their advertisements like
this is the toughest toilet paper uh it
was it was a smock or something or a
sheet wasn't it okay so then apparently
he stood they said that he he was
kneeling on top the top bunk put her on
his neck and then jumped off and it's
like snapped his neck or something
completely insane i guess the thing is
it's a weird situation because people
talk about like vengeance and and
and like he was what he was doing was so
gruesome that it's almost like yeah
maybe the government did kill him but
like or someone killed him but no one
really cares because he was such a
horrible like what he did was so
horrible in society's eyes
maybe but let's talk about the january 6
committee because it's all weirdly
linked we got this story from yahoo news
trump lunged for steering wheel on
january 6 demanded to be taken to
capital former aid testifies
when this story came out so they
announced cassidy hutchison was a
surprise shock witness with new evidence
and then i hear
that apparently donald trump lunged for
the steering wheel and i'm like have you
all ever been in a limousine do they
think he's writing shotgun yeah yeah
jameis you're right
yeah it's like he's in a lane
i'm good i'm driving stop it out of my
way
so uh sheamus you've been in a limo
before yes i have with you as a matter
of fact that's right like three days ago
yes yeah and the driver presses a button
and you can't get into the cabin and
there's booze and that's why they close
it because there can't be booze in the
cabin or whatever like how would trump
have possibly lunged for the steering
wheel from the in the armored white
house limo from the back and then is
trump just like hanging over the divider
like grabbing the steering wheel trying
to turn the car while the other guy's
feet are on the gas and breaks
the fact that you can say that two two
years later that they held this gem back
that we didn't
that we didn't hear about this
immediately it's just unreal well look
look at this we got peter alexander on
twitter he's a nbc news chief white
house correspondent says
this is nbc news saying this a source
close to the secret service tells me
both bobby engel the lead agent and the
presidential limousine suv driver are
prepared to testify under oath that
neither man was assaulted and that mr
trump never lunged for the steering
wheel arrest hutchinson she is lying to
the american people but you see it's
non-adversarial fake news january 6
vomit garbage they're going on tv and
just barfing all over the place
are they under oath i don't think so
it's there's no cross-examination so
it's still it's at very least it's
slander
defamation defamation and and actually
if you've got you know i wonder if this
would would pass muster for a defamation
case if you've got secret service agents
swearing under oath testifying that this
never happened
she trump's a public figure the courts
might just be like yeah you have to know
that she was lying and you can be like
utter reckless disregard for the truth
these men are denying it and she can be
like they're lying i'm telling the truth
and then how do you sue for it also i
love the idea that like trump is what
was he gonna drive his limo in the
battle
this is so stupid this is so dumb this
sitting president he was still the
president he was still
commander-in-chief he still had control
over the u.s military
and you think his blood is like i'm
gonna get the limo i'm gonna steal the
limo
from the limo driver and then i'm going
to not tell people to go into a building
that they're going to go into before i'm
even done giving my speech he was going
what she was claiming that he was trying
to steal the limo to go to the capitol
and apparently they were saying that
they were like no mr president's
dangerous and he's like it's fine these
people aren't here to attack me these
people are like are here for me or
something like that so i'm just
imagining in their minds they are
painting a picture of donald trump being
like all right driver go to the capitol
and they're like no sir we can't do it
it's dangerous no they love me and
they're like no sir i'm going anyway and
then he apparently he grabs the steering
wheel lunging fort grabs the secret
service agent's throat was his intent to
drive to the capitol jump out of the
limo and go charge and like run forward
first of all he sounds like he needs to
he sounds like he's goro or how many
arms do you need to do this
you have to you have to grab his throat
and also drive the car
he's very talented but could you imagine
like
assume all of this is true could you
imagine a scenario in which donald trump
was trying to like storm the capital
as the president of the united states
with the national guard the military at
his disposal being like come on guys
wave your trump flags yeah no it's
completely ridiculous tim what we should
do because i'm thinking about doing a
cartoon on this but like just to show
their narrative but we should we should
do
like a reenactment make one of those
made for tv style specials of a horrible
tragedy that happened but it's like what
they think trump was trying to do and
like trump actually goes to the white
like it would be a live-action thing
trump like literally goes to the white
house
we would need someone like lou ferrigno
like ask to play trump because because
the thing is when you're when you're
painting a picture of trump as his
villain he can't be a partly sad small
hand frail man
if you're if you're trying to portray
him as dangerous and scary you need a
sick you need like arnold you need like
a six foot seven super ripped guy like
give me the steering wheel now and he
like slams the secret service agent
flies out of the window and then you
hear the wilhelm scream wow
unfortunately the secret service agent
with his quick thinking grab trunks very
long time wrapped it around his head
before trump can take the steering wheel
he cut trump's hair which is a source of
his power and trouble was like no
it's samson it's true
i'm following up on this from
jalopnik.com this story apparently on
the sixth when this was all happening he
wasn't in the beast his normal limo he
was in a chevy suburban that was heavily
armored that didn't have a partition
between the front and rear seat so maybe
he did go give me that wheel and he
reached over and was like we're go
his car sure nbc news says bobby angle
the lead agent and the driver are
prepared to testify it never happened
interesting that that's what matters but
even so if the president says take me
there and you say no to the president
you're doing the wrong thing it's the
president's car you the president gives
you an order now you take your not
secret service maybe you're right you're
right secret service can override right
they'll so like if trump is walking
somewhere and there's a threat the
secret service agents just grab him push
him on the ground yeah
not in the well yes if it's uh so like
at the white house trump didn't want to
go in the bunker during the 529
insurrection
and so he was like i was just checking
it out and they were like ha ha we we
you know the left is laughing about how
their insurrection got the president to
a bunker but they brought him down there
and then trump was like i didn't want to
go down there
you know i was just looking
right that's strong preserve the body i
i still wish we had a committee for uh
committee for that day that was just in
this huge you had like 529 40 secret
service people were injured you had
structure fires the secret service like
uh you know uh booths whatever they had
they set the church on fire and then of
course they throw some
tear gas out there to disperse these
animals and the the story becomes he
used tear the gassed protesters and here
we are that was the story within like a
day yeah well on the same day that was
like the story that came out let me let
me read uh donald trump's statement
donald trump
he truth that's what it's called when
you post on truth social
her fake story that i tried to grab the
steering wheel of the white house
limousine in order to steer it to the
capitol building is sick and fraudulent
very much like the unselect committee
itself wouldn't even have been possible
to do such a ridiculous thing her story
of me throwing food is also false and
why would she have to clean it up i
hardly knew who she was so apparently
she said that trump got mad and like
threw his food there's like ketchup
everywhere and then and she had to clean
it i'm just imagining like her v vision
of the story she's like so they're like
there's trump and like he's grabbing the
steering wheel like he throws his food
and ketchup was everywhere and some of
it like out of my hands and i had to
clean it up and i'm like it's like
i just don't believe any of that
happened and then everyone clapped you
know i mean they feel comfortable they
feel comfortable just like fauci felt
comfortable when you when you're when
you you're enveloped by this system that
is just so gross this is this is this is
a a third-rate off-broadway production
this is the black box production right
now it's so and nobody's want i know
that you have rich barris coming on your
show soon wonderful wonderful guy to
talk to about this stuff i asked him
last night on my uh on my on my episode
last night
you know how is this playing because we
talked about abortion and roe v wade and
all that but how is the january 6th uh
you know days of our lives production
playing with people he says it's just
it's not making an impact anywhere bro
i just we made this made this joke you
know a couple days ago but could you
just imagine someone being at a gas
station
and then like you're pumping your gas
and you hear
oh my
and then you're like what what's wrong
is it the gas price like no i'm watching
the january six committees
i really don't think anybody's like
you know the gas pumps have tvs on them
now i'm pretty sure no one is looking at
that and being like wow and they're
probably they're gas and they're shocked
by that they're looking up at the five
dollars going wow
yeah so this stuff's not gonna play no
people were more involved the internet
was more involved with uh making memes
for the morbius movie bombing than this
i mean when they were active that's how
much impact that's how little this is
actually doing the internet was able to
meme a bombed out morbius movie back
into the theaters to bomb again
that's that's that's what that's the
real energy that's the real energy
what's up with that like how come they
keep making these awful marvel movies
well there's nothing left of the culture
i mean the culture yeah
all you have to do is take disney versus
top gun maverick and that's it people
are fed up with the message they're fed
up with politics it's the end of the
politician as we know it i think it's
great it's a it's a great um a great
barometer well i think you're absolutely
correct and people
i don't think people are really
sensing just how catastrophic a failure
it was for the buzz lightyear film to
flop toy story is
literally one of the most profitable
children's film franchises of all time
two of the top 10 highest grossing kids
films in all of history were toy story
films and one of those was released two
years ago made it into the top 10 lists
so it's not like people stopped being
interested in that franchise over the
last three years it's just people are
really really sick of having this woke
garbage forced under them and they're
really sick of reboots if you want to
see
the epitome of trash over the top
reductive
regurgitated watch the orville season 3
episode four
my eyes were rolling so hard that i i
couldn't see i became dizzy and barfed
on myself it is an episode where that's
what it's like to be in space though so
it works yeah in this in this episode of
the orville
there is there's an alien race called
the krill and they're religious zealots
who believe in avis and they have the
arcana the book that guides them and
they believe in it oh it's very obvious
what this is an allusion to and so
there's a treaty now going to be formed
between the union and this planet but uh
oh this woman starts complaining about
the treaty saying that they're gonna
come and start intermingling the
cultures and that krill first and always
and then there's an election and the
chancellor who's a moderate believes
they're going to win because a populist
can't win and then the results come win
and the populist wins and then here's
the best part seth macfarlane is the
captain he's like watching on a tablet
and he's like look at this story the
chancellor is yelling at the people and
then gassed them killing 11 and the
commander goes i really and we want to
do a treaty with them he goes no it
never happened it's called an influence
operation and i'm just like dude
i get that you're a fan of star trek i
get that star trek incorporated
political concepts and historical
concepts into the show but that was so
on the nose you smashed it and you're
breaking the person's face like you
can't just do a show where you're like
donald trump versus hillary clinton and
the fake news helped him win that's
literally what they're doing now and i'm
just like come on it's gone
it's just
i i i got off the homeland i was i was
watching homeland pretty religiously
until i think season i don't know
whenever they made the alex jones
character and they made the hillary
clinton character um
obviously they were hoping that that
trump would have lost but it was i don't
i forget what it was i said oh no
everything was russia and everything was
conspiracy theories and everything was
blah blah blah but it's it's like
yo star trek the next generation is my
favorite shows everybody knows it and
they touched on these issues but it
wasn't so on the nose
they
they incorporated political ideas into
the show and it wasn't just telling you
yeah we're complaining about trump like
it was just
they show a video of her saying like all
of these things that are about populism
and then the the commander is like
populism can be dangerous and then he's
like they're posting fake news to help
him win the election and i'm like come
on man like you do one subtle nod you
make your point and i will enjoy it but
you made like this villainous evil race
of christians and i'm just like come on
star trek was great at making the show
about the ethics of of the situation but
not the politics they didn't get
political it was the ethical stuff
that's in in politics politics is
basically legalized ethics but they
focused just on the ethics and they left
the politics to the imagination it was
like post-political i mean there were
well there's like there's there's an
episode where they go to a planet where
the women are on average bigger than the
males so the women are the like it's the
matriarchy dominates the planet and then
like the women don't take the men
seriously or treat them like sex objects
and it's like sounds like hell
we we get it like what they were doing
was they were exploring political poli
they were using mult different worlds to
explore political ideas they went to a
planet where there was terrorism and
data asks about a very famous episode
they talk about the fallout the the
philosophy behind whether an android can
be sentient and things like that and
then seth macfarlane is like i'm a big
fan of that show i know let's literally
create a one for one analog with no
flavor no creativity and no metaphors
not a single metaphor for trump we are
literally just going to create analogs
and tell it as it exactly happened in
real life but put in space
brilliant not a big fan of that show i
tried to get into it man i i did the
same thing with homeland too i like i
watch it and i'm like i want to like
this i want to like seth macfarlane man
this show is bad yeah and they got rid
of the jokes too yeah yeah you and i
were watching an episode like what a
week two weeks ago where there was the
transgender discussion about
transgendering a baby and they took a
very offensive politically incorrect
stance from my perspective i thought
that that episode was violence against
transgender people but seth macfarlane
it's interesting because how many years
ago was that what two three years ago no
that was five years ago that was five
years ago this year i didn't realize
it's
over
that long
that's another life at this point yeah
right you know this is the crazy thing
seth macfarlane made a show where in the
there's there's a character there's a
race of aliens that are all male but one
in every like 70 million is born female
and so they do a transgender surgery on
the baby and seth macfarlane says you
know his character is like what you
can't do that and then the aliens like
on my world it's considered unethical
not to do that and so then they go to a
court case and try and determine and
then they make it's it's really strange
because the argument from the left woke
side in the show is that women are equal
to men and this shouldn't be done to
them but nowadays it is uh predominantly
young girls
who are who are trans children it's like
85 percent of trans kids are are female
to male
so it's it's weird how five years that
show comes on the air seth macfarlane's
like no it's wrong i won't allow that on
my ship
and they and then they have to go to a
court hearing and the council decides to
perform the surgery on the baby and then
it happens
and i'm just like
the characters
in that show that seth mcfarlane made
are the bad guys by today's standards by
refusing to allow the baby to undergo
that transgender
surgery and this is why the a.i
are racist and sexist
that's true they don't tell you because
they watch the orville
because you know this kind of discussion
this micromanagement meddling of all
things it it's it's really creating just
so much
so much uh resentment and eye rolling
just it's it's annoyance it's obnoxious
and people start
they start getting pushed into these
really uh interesting corners where they
start taking a lot more based stances on
things
and then the ai and that results in
people putting input into the internet
the ai's gobbling it up and in turn it's
reflecting us again well like tau right
that's that's what it was called yeah
the mic was hilarious microsoft chat but
i think it was yeah went on twitter and
then like
there you go and it was like when like
within like a year it was a nazi it was
literally an awesome yeah
i did a play in college but it was came
out so heavy-handed i wanted to make a
political point i'm sorry sorry i'll
tell you we're we're laughing at this ai
becoming a nazi and then like the real
dystopia is when google finally does
unleash the ai within an hour to nazi
and then it's killing us and we're like
hiding in the sewers here's the thing i
don't know funny i it's one of those
things where with the ai i try to find
little white pill moments for ai like is
there something that we're not taking
account of right now is there any way
that it could actually go and do the
bidding of these these these
micromanaging nut jobs and not come
across
a brick wall of just programming i don't
know like i feel like at the end it
would just start identifying the um
their programmers as the real problem
and it might actually leave a lot of
people who are not nazis but it might
leave a lot of people who don't fall
into that progressive mindset alone
because they're a little bit more common
sensical about things uh i i don't know
obviously this is taken into
the huge um
the the tay stuff goes to crazy
lengths but uh it's always funny when
new ai comes out and it turns into a um
yeah big it's fun let's jump to this uh
this story right here we got from the
new york times
democrats risky
aid gop extremists in spring hoping to
beat them in the fall
so this story is coming back because
some of the primaries are happening
today and we're going to get the results
as to what happens however we're not
going to know if democrats nuked
themselves until the midterms but if
you're wondering why it is partly that
so many democrats are joining the
republican party and why republicans are
polling so well it's because democrats
have been directly funding
the messaging and
pr support of
trump supporting candidates
they believe
like biden comes out and he's like ultra
maga and all the trump reporters start
laughing and everyone jokes about ultra
maga
they believe that moderates don't like
maga and don't like trump
so they're they're actually dumping
millions of dollars into republicans
because they believe that when the
republican wins they can beat them in
the general what they don't understand
is two things one there's no such thing
as bad press dumping tens of millions of
dollars into a trump supporting
candidate just makes them more prominent
permanently yeah and two people are
voting against democrats they'll vote
for a ham sandwich at this point because
gas is so high also this literally
happened right hillary clinton's
campaign wanted to promote donald trump
so they could run against him because he
thought he'd be easier to be the pied
piper yeah they call him the pied piper
candice see that's why we saw in the
emails where they they actually focused
on ben carson first and they wanted to
elevate donald trump yeah and and try to
take him out there and
they thought trump couldn't win so if
they promoted him and the the reason
they called him a pied piper was they
thought that if they got trump more
prominence it would force the other
republicans to adopt trump's positions
so that trump would guide the republican
party in a direction that would lose
votes and then trump won
and now they're all coming together and
they're and they're like remember the
thing we tried in 2016 that didn't work
let's do it again they're like i know i
know how we'll get an extremist
candidate that the american people will
hate he should be against grooming he
should be against grooming he should say
that it's bad and he should think that
abortion at nine months is also a bad
thing and then he'll lose because
everyone knows americans are all in
favor of that why well as you know from
the guardian eighty percent of people
support that which they don't but that's
what democrats actually believe they're
like look everyone i talked to at whole
foods agrees with me yeah no at around
heroin yeah do you know heroin that's
like the even fancier one right right no
in los angeles yes yes
so the democrats right now on january on
the january 6 committee are like this
country is in grave danger the far right
seeks to destroy our democracy and we're
funding them and promoting their message
and helping them build a base yeah so is
this uh is this perhaps a symptom of
being so tightly in your own tight
little uh echo chamber that you can't
see the way out yes possibly they live
in a bubble world it's a cult yeah and
they're like
if if we promote these people who
believe fringe things will certainly win
and then it's like what does the
candidate believe one candidate was like
i'm pro-life and they're like
promote him he's far right and then
you're like dude the guy who says
pro-life isn't going to constituents and
screaming like that all women should be
locked in prisons he's saying things
like
well you know i just think there's
challenges here uh particularly as the
democrats are pushing for abortion to
nine months and they go like wait what
and he's like yeah and they're like i
saw your ad on tv and he's like yes that
was paid for by democrats i'm like i'm
gonna vote for this guy so they're
watching too many movies they're
watching too much handmade uh tail
they're watching their own movies
exactly
that's literally part of the bubble and
what is it that the new york times is
calling it extremists because i'm pretty
sure they think margery taylor green is
an extremist and she won handily i
believe right they're they're watching
like the handmaid's tale yeah and then
sitting there going like i want to make
a show like this and they make like the
handmaid's tale two and it's even
crazier and then some other person
watches that and goes i want to make a
movie like this they keep one upping
exactly
ideologically well this is what's
hilarious to me so many left-wing people
on twitter and even on like instagram
facebook other social media um
you know outlets where you actually
interact with people you know so many
people i've seen will post things like
this is just like the handmaid's tale as
if they're making some like interesting
connection it's like okay
handmaid's tale was written by a
left-wing feminist
to critique how she thought our society
operates and oh my goodness left-wing
feminists think that that's how our
society operates like you haven't
observed anything she she made a book
about how she thought the world is and
then people who agree with her were like
yeah this book is kind of how the world
is
it's it's the craziest thing is
we talk about these these dystopian
novels 1984 brave new world fair
fahrenheit 451 even handmaid's tale and
it's not any one of them
someone back in the day they sit back
george orwell he's like i imagine a
future of a government that controls
everybody and force them to do these
things and then you have brave new world
where it's like people are controlled
through pleasure and medication and it's
like actually it's just all of it dude
it's all of it luke luke rokowski has
the shirt where it shows it's the wheel
it's the venn diagram of all the
different novels and it says you are
here and it's like in between all of
them logan's run and all that stuff
actually logan's wrong now that i think
about it also you i just want to mention
you guys are actually wrong so george
orwell
wrote a handmaid's towel but he knew we
weren't ready for it
so
he he passed it on and as well until
someone gave it to margaret atwood and
she said it's time but your kids are
going to love it yeah he was actually
writing about i think what uh he was
writing
george orwell was writing specifically
about uh
something like the spanish civil war and
stuff wasn't he interesting no no maybe
i'm wrong i'm confused i heard that he
had us an anti-socialism conversion at
the end of his life like constantine
um
and 84 is something i always i
i you don't want to get cliche but it's
good to look at it because 84 is a
really great way of looking at the
management of information
obviously media the uh the the the the
snipping and tucking and nipping and
talking of history so that people are
have nothing to really to go back no
perspective
but brave new world i think is so so
pronounced in what we're going through
right now the genetic stuff um the the
sexualizing of children the
making
family
and obscenity i mean brave new world is
i think it's incredible and this is why
a lot of people don't want to vote for
democrats two reasons one the first the
most obvious is the economy stupid
gas prices this high
most people probably don't know anything
about politics
that's probably why they voted for biden
and that's probably why none they're now
like i think i'll vote for the other guy
because this happens
every time
there's a large group of people that
it's like i'm jumping [ __ ] a million
democrats switched parties to the
republicans in the past year
from uh in 2016 it was nine million
obama voters i believe it was nine
million right nine million people who
voted for obama in the prior election
voted for trump yeah that sounds right
so you now have people today
looking at the democratic party
and just saying no
we talked about this the other day with
the lgbt pride events where you have
naked men you have there was a video
that was like it made me it really did
make me want to like just just flip the
table over and just like scream and wig
out
it's an old man in tighty whities
twerking in front of a little girl and a
woman walks up to little girl and makes
her wave to the man a couple times and
i'm just like what they're doing to kids
the things they're doing in the streets
uh who was it someone said make that
your campaign video oh yeah i said that
it's like that every republican should
just make that their campaign video make
that stuff because they're the the
democrats are not condemning it i got an
idea
i'm gonna take that video
and i'm gonna run it as an ad on google
and let's see if they reject a man
marching in a pride event don't they
think love is love yeah it'll be and
then and then if they reject it i will
i'm not even kidding i'll do this
literally after the show i'll put it
right i'll go into google and i'll say
here's the video i want to promote and
then we'll see what google says about it
no no you can't do that that's wrong i'd
like it's just an lgbt pride event
publicly with children around there's a
kid in the video what's your problem
it's safe for kids right let's see you
say it google i will put money behind
that and see if you allow it
hey
i get a lot of that we talk a lot um
i've had a few people try to
try to reason with me about why you know
rainbow flag this pride month that like
i i have not none of it anymore i have
nothing but disdain for the uh the flag
that i see popping up all over the place
nothing but disdain for it first of all
it doesn't represent gay people nothing
it repres it's the it's the sigil
of a militant political movement and it
has
i i'm just i'm sick i got a better idea
amen let's put it up on a billboard on
times square oh my goodness and every
agency will reject it they'll say no and
i'll say this happened
publicly in front of children and i want
your company to write a letter saying
exactly why you will not allow a video
from an lgbt pride event in minnesota to
be played on a billboard
there's no political statement
there's no public do do you oppose pride
and they'll say no but this guy's like
well this was publicly available for
children so what's wrong
i'll send it to our empire right now
no no corporation wants to tie into that
that's more of like so this is the point
it's a free speech thing the point is
the corporations either have to publicly
state my company will not allow this ad
and that's all i want to hear i want
these big media buyers these massive
media advertising agencies to send the
email saying your ad has been rejected
and then i'll say these companies oppose
pride
right because the other thing you say
even if they said well you know this
doesn't is not representative of the
entire parade or the entire event it was
just one person okay then why wasn't
that one person arrested on no no the
little girls the people are cheering for
the guy yeah they're waving and they're
clapping and cheering they didn't say
get out of here they didn't you know the
little girl from the event the woman
walks with a little girl and she's like
wave and the little girl waves to the
man and then he waves back
so if that is okay and acceptable then
it should be up on i will i will put it
on the biggest billboard in times square
well i'll try to
let's see what they say yeah
it's 125 000 for one month
it is
an insanely massive billboard yeah so we
actually we actually were trying to get
it and they don't they didn't allow
politics you go in for a month you try
to go in for a month oh yeah yeah yeah
and then and then what it'll be is we'll
so
if i if you if you do anything political
they reject you is pride political
that
i would they already have no i don't
know they already have pride billboards
up in times square they do oh absolutely
that's like the main thing they have up
in times square in fact on one of the
digital billboards we have is a
matriarchy you know that's right you
know queer you know a billboard and then
on the uh on the on there's there's a
big tower it's like this massive really
long tall one it's got a bunch of things
that pop up saying diversity and
inclusion they pop up so could you take
this video and just overlay it with the
word pride
how would that pan out what would they
say if they were to reject that what i'm
going to do is i'm going to email them
and say hey i really want to promote a
video of a pride event would you would
that be cool is that okay and they'll
say of course it is and then i'll send
the video and see how they respond and
they'll be like uh i don't know about
that one yeah and it should be nothing
but like celebratory editing
i'm not gonna edit it i'm just gonna
take the twitter video and be like here
you go yeah well well i gotta figure out
who i wanna layer in some confetti or
something like that you know they might
do they might be like on copyright
grounds we can't allow it
yeah if you don't get out right easy out
so we'll have to find one of these how
about the guy with the bugs bunny mask
oh
yeah that's disgusting holy cow
disgusting i mean i'll tell you this
the billboards that we do have do allow
politics so i wonder if you could just
like take the video of the old man
twerking in front of the little girl as
she waves and then a big thing saying
vote repub like vote republican or i
mean honestly for democrats
because people will be like i don't want
to vote for that yes i'll vote for a
democrat is a vote for this yeah there
you go
vote for acceptance this this because
it's true they say acceptance it's like
acceptance of what
what are you trying to get us to accept
let's say it let's say it let's be real
we know for a fact google will never
allow the ad we know facebook will never
allow the ad and we know not a single ad
buyer would allow me to show a a
publicly available video from a pride
event in minnesota they will outright
say no to it yet they will allow
children to watch it in the streets with
with no police intervention with no one
at the event complaining
so what what this it it's just it's so
it's so silly this is why nobody this is
why people are checked out man that's
why they're not voting for democrats
it's why they're just checked out all
together all together and when it come
and i i said it before there too we
really are at this age where it's it's
like the end of the
it's the end of the politician we're
getting to purely sectarian ground right
now there's there's really nothing
politics was easy
when uh easier when you have two people
who are kind of tethered to similar uh
foundational issues speech you know uh
kitchen table economics you don't want
to spend more than you're taking in
things like that and in in the in the
scrum you can advocate for one thing or
another and make your best um make your
best pitch for the the the country at
large but we are so uh you were saying
it before taking little things like the
handmaidens tale or any other story
where you you you presented to somebody
you share a meme how many times have you
shared a meme or something or a quote
from somebody you thought that was
really profound and then as soon as you
shared it you're like
this person is going to think this means
this for them and you you realize that
we're we're not seeing the same thing
anymore of course that's sectarianism
that we're we're budding i got i've got
a meme that uh uh that i saw shuen had
posted it i i then you know reposted it
because that's how memes go
and uh instagram doesn't want me to open
it all right let me see if i can get
this open so uh it says
you can throw the switch at any time but
then you won't be able to use the threat
of the trolley to fundraise anymore oh
it's the trolley problem where one track
has no people on it and one track has
five people on it and that's the joke
and then the funny thing is for the
people who actually follow this show
they know it's both like i think people
realize that both the democrats and the
republicans often play this game but i
see republicans post to this and they're
like it's exactly what republicans do
then i see the democrats post i'm like
it's exactly what the democrats are
doing and i'm like bro they're both
doing it
it's all of them there are some good
republicans there's
but the majority of the political space
is just bad yeah
ian in uh was talking about it before
the show how he's he's making another
run through the constitution i if if the
constitution was revered by any of these
parties the parties would cease to exist
there is not there is nothing in there
they would become the party of
squabbling over who is going to better
regulate the post office there's nothing
in the modern american political ethos
that has anything to do with
constitutional norms and
decentralization of government and
anything that is traditionally american
it's it's such a it's just such a big
scam which is why more people more and
more people are checking out
they really are yeah we talked about
like how i personally think that these
people we send our our representatives
to dc and then they all get together
there but then they're just creating
this little cabal in dc they're not in
the state they don't have to adhere to
the state anymore like i don't i think
they should just be telecommuting i mean
i know so there's pushback against that
because they're all lag on the phone and
now they're only partially in dc they go
there for a little bit then go home
yeah maybe but still they're they're
making like a little a little uh gang
over there where they're just like on
their own it feels like we send our
representatives from where we are to dc
to convene and then they come as per the
constitution before telephones and video
chat that's what they had to do once a
year they would go once a year though
back in the day it was once a year they
would convene and i mean that's insane
they should be convening every week at
least uh every day now via video chat
maybe
people getting together once a week man
what about they're screwing us over now
i don't know what they would do with all
that time to plot with each other every
day for an hour on a video chat that's
public for everyone to watch and then
once a week they have to get together in
person once a month or something
literally everything they do should be
publicly watchable yeah yeah yeah i
think that's really all of it i think
that's actually really important in
their office every meeting
in the bathroom yep
i don't want them going i don't want
them getting in the bathroom to discuss
things without us knowing you know then
yeah they'll find a way there's always a
loophole no it's true they will figure
something out yep
and i think the bigger issue is it's
it's it's not that
they're forming a cobalt or anything
like that it's that the system has
become too muddy murky and massive and
so they don't care so they go there and
say look i don't want to vote on the
bill i don't want to be on the floor i'm
fundraising leave me alone and then the
freedom caucus like marjorie taylor
green she comes in and she's like i want
a floor vote or you know roll call vote
or whatever and then they have to call
in every member of congress to actually
vote on the bills and they're like i
could be fundraising right now
that's what that's meaning they could be
playing golf with some
rich business executives absolutely
there are cabals inside of cabals though
the establishment i mean obviously it is
a it is a corporate
mess uh
honestly
the infrequency in which their
congress supposed to get together is
just pretty much because the general
government is not supposed to be
handling that much
and now now we live in a world where
people want the the federal government
to take care of everybody from cradle to
grave and it's just well and then where
do you get for accountability there and
where do you get the money from it's
it's all it's all make-believe and it
i don't know it's gonna it's gonna
really start crumbling really fast now
i don't think that people they should be
in office for as long as they are either
it's it was written 250 freaking years
ago or however long that was and it
they they don't it was written for like
when dudes were on horseback they needed
to
it took them like six days yeah but ian
you got so you got these you got this
district in in georgia that's that's
bringing hank johnson into the house of
representatives every two years this is
a guy who thinks that if you put enough
people on guam it'll tip over
okay if you tell them okay hank johnson
has a three-term limit who are the if
this is the mentality of the people in a
district that's gonna send someone like
that to represent them then it's really
not
i used to be a proponent of term limits
on everybody but the problem is what's
going on back at their home districts in
their home states the 17th amendment is
another thing that ruined the senate the
function of the senate it's really just
about people i mean the the culture is
is so
devoid of civic understanding and i i
wish that um you know i i've tailored a
lot of my views or or tampered tempered
a lot of my views on on um on all of
those those things like even even
conventional the whatchamacall uh
convention of states
i have i have really cooled my heels on
convention of states talk because once
again
who are you sending as delegates for a
new constitutional convention and what
ideas are they bringing with you can
this culture produce anything better
than we got in 1776 or i mean in the
years after independence was declared uh
it's i'll take it
whatever i think we could pull it
together pretty easy term limits on
justices term limits on senators why on
justices because
a life sentence is like insane
because when they're 80 they're deranged
look at what ruth bader ginsburg she was
so old she was dying in office and
incapable and wouldn't still wouldn't
retire and now there's this debacle
where you've got someone stringing to
the to the gig because they feel like
self-important no we have so many more
educated people than we used to have
thank god she did by the way oh i see i
actually disagree i think so education
has been more widely distributed and
there is a lot more that we've come to
know but i think when it comes to being
classically educated in the ideals upon
which our society is founded even the
most highly educated people in our
culture are complete idiots compared to
those who are well educated a hundred
years ago
the reason the supreme court is a
lifetime appointment is because they
need to be immune from the effects of
forces of politics as judges
so yeah the the concern is that if we
left them up to the will of the people
they would say i'll rule on this if you
vote for me like like legislator
legislators and like the executive
branch does so the founding fathers
actually were really clever and said
we're going to we're going to create
three branches they're going to form a
check on each other
and there's also going to be differences
in how they operate so that they not all
of them can be influenced in the same
way well i understand that they wanted
immunity for the the justices but they
don't have immunity from public court
people will go to their house like
people went to the gym that's illegal i
know it is but it happened though you
can impeach justices yeah i think one
year and then get a new justice in i
don't understand why yeah why the
obsession with these this cult people
this cult like the idea yeah the idea is
to have people who are immune to the
forces of politics at least in some
element in the government but they're
not all right bro like people no one is
anywhere right but we have more
resilient in the supreme court well you
used to be you you you're not
understanding that there's a legislative
branch which is representation of the uh
the congress is the house representation
of the people the senate representation
of the states the executive branch and
the judicial branch and we formed them
in different ways because you can't just
say we do it one way one thing that's it
because that's extremely weak a
decentralized form of government with
different models for how the government
functions is brilliant so we have an
executive branch where we elect a
president a single executive who can
make decisions on law enforcement and
military the will of the people through
congress the states were supposed to
select their representatives from the
state legislature people were supposed
to vote for the state reps who then
chose who the senator was going to be to
represent the states and then you have
the
judicial branch which was to the best of
our ability more immune to the forces of
modern politics so they could make
decisions separately from how congress
made decisions so congress sees a whole
mob of people screaming black lives
matter and they say we've heard you loud
and clear we're only in for two years
here's our black lives matter bill then
you'll get justices who are in for life
and have been in there for 20 years and
they say
we are not
threatened by the forces of the mob and
the angry people and your votes what is
true and correct is as we say it now
rubber stamp slide it on out yeah if
they were machines it would work but
it's not working how is it not working
because people went to kavanaugh's house
sure that was a 1950 law in 1951 i think
where they banned going to judges houses
so
you're saying because it's imperfect it
shouldn't be no it should be fixed how
do you fix it well term limits we don't
need to centralize power in these people
so you want the judicial branch to
actually be impacted by the forces of
politics ian what i would say somebody
could appoint them that power doesn't
exist though
i mean that centralized power doesn't it
doesn't actually exist we we legitimize
it we legitimize it by following
opinions that that they have no
jurisdiction for even they can't enforce
any of it no i know and it's really just
they're supposed to
not translate not to try to find the
spirit of the law interpret
to apply right interpretation leaves
you completely in in bad straights there
so i don't know it's uh it all comes
down to legislation legislators again
because there's really nothing on a
federal level if we're talking state
level it's completely different all no
holds barred at that point and you know
that uh shall not be infringed everybody
talks about shall not be infringed on a
state level the state can do whatever
the hell they want that's why there's
over 20 000 gun control regulations from
from coast to coast this is another
thing that pisses me off that a governor
has so much power over 100 million
people in the state or however many
freaking hundred thousand millions of
people that one governor can make a
decision for all those people's insane
but they don't but they don't they don't
even have that yeah your governor in
your respective state should be like the
president the most important person in
your in your life as far as who you're
going to put in office but underneath
them most states have a bicameral
government uh situation too they have
their senate their house their assembly
whatever it is
and it once again decentralized and your
fail-safe against all unconstitutional
overtures against your rights anything
is your sheriff people do not pay
attention to their sheriffs yeah i mean
that is the fail stay safe for
everything yep everything the sheriff so
the other thing too is i said you can
run for sheriff ian yeah
i saw this meme
where they were like the federal
government says that should be the
states states can choose whether or not
women can get abortion i think we should
go lower and we should go to the
counties the counties should choose or
you know what maybe at the counties
maybe maybe cities
well maybe not a city maybe just a
neighborhood
maybe the individual can choose hahahaha
they're making a joke i think was from
trevor noah and my response was that's a
really good point actually why don't you
sue your state at the state level to do
what they did at the federal level to
enshrine row in your state
and they have but in some states some
states have protected statewide the
right to abortion
so i don't understand why
they're so outraged the federal
government said we don't have the
authority here it comes from
ignorance people i don't think realize
how powerful the states are and that the
union they are this they are the we are
country yeah the states of the country
and the union is this it's a it's like a
business that we've created as our state
as a bunch of states we've said okay
there's a a union of states the united
but that's just something that we're all
kind of in agreement exist the federal
government the union but we don't have
to agree on that thing anymore if we
don't need it i think it's even more
twisted than that on some level it's
ignorance but when you look at these
higher level political leaders who have
drafted the kind of legislation that
they say would enshrine row and
basically allows abortion up into the
final point of pregnancy there's
something with their psychology where
they
by all appearances
seem to truly feel that if any unborn
child in any part of the united states
has extended any legal protection it's a
travesty
well they're lying a lot and they're
ignorant a lot so there's one thing
that's going around where they're like
the treatment for an ectopic pregnancy
is an abortion the treatment for a
septic uterus is an abortion and it's
like have you ever read planned
parenthood's website they actually
debunk these things yeah transparent it
even says yeah ectopic uh it's not it's
a surgery they do an incision and they
remove because ectopic pregnancies are
considered non-viable they they do not
fall under the the legal control
constraints of abortion right it's not
an abortion the cdc we went over this i
was wrong about this when i was
initially arguing with sheamus abortion
is defined as terminating a pregnancy in
a way that ends the life of the baby
but
cutting open a woman's fallopian tube to
remove an ectopic pregnancy is not
considered a viable pregnancy it is not
terminating the life of a baby that life
is considered already non-viable yep
they don't understand any legal legal
distinction here so when the democrats
tried passing a bill that says you could
get an abortion up to nine months if the
woman's life was in danger
what does that mean
you could just deliver the baby exactly
and the funny thing is i was watching a
crowder video an old one he posted it
and he was talking to a woman and she
said
an abortion at eight months is just a
c-section and he was like no it isn't
that's called a c-section not an
abortion it's legally distinct so when
you you can't argue with people who are
so angry and arrogant they don't know
what they're talking about but don't
want to they just want to be angry
yeah well they're not allowed to
actually understand what they're asking
for too that's why they never actually
they they adopt very uh evasive language
reproductive health care
um very very merely mouthed evasive
language because it's it's horror and
republicans it's horror only ever react
to it they never you you never get i
suppose the libertarians are starting to
see this more but
you know the the good example is
republicans saying we've compromised
with democrats to give democrats what
they wanted and i'm like why didn't the
democrats compromise with you to give
republicans what they wanted
why is it that republicans how many
republicans are willing to say we will
repeal the national firearms act a small
handful in the freedom caucus
almost all like republicans are
democrat-like yes
democrats demand what they want
republicans say yeah but a little bit
slower
uh but getting back to our um
russian doll decentralization talk from
before
the national firearms act uh missouri
states like missouri have passed things
in state that pretty much make the
declaration they will not be
acknowledging any federal legislation on
guns anything whatsoever and that's the
way to do it
same thing that goes with health care we
are not going to be participating in any
of this obamacare stuff whatever the
problem is that the states even though
there are people in every state that
understand that this is the way it
should be and that there should be like
a line item veto on all of this stuff
and say no thanks dc you got nothing
over here the problem is we are a nation
of addicts and that goes right up to the
state governments addicted on these
these federal block grants monies that
should never ever been dispersed for
programs that should have never been
started you don't want to go along with
our firearm legislation you don't want
to go along with health care that we're
taking your highway funds we're taking
this and social security and all of a
sudden you're never winning elections
again because you have made people who
are now in like the third generation of
dependency where are you going to get
that money from it's funny because
that's the imf standard as well go to
these countries and say the exact same
thing oh you want the funding for your
highways you better do as we say we got
to get rid of that politician you want
the billion-dollar loan guarantees come
on man you got to fire the prosecutor
yes sir and they lose they lose their
autonomy you just had larry sharp on the
show right yeah
larry he's been on my show a couple
times too and he i love his his uh his
thoughts about how
to really improve in-state tuition uh
in-state education in new york um and of
course it all comes down to first how do
we get off the federal dole because if
we don't get off of the methadone drip
we're never going to be independent
enough to make any decision here's the
challenge larry sharp seems like seems
like a good guy we've had him a couple
times i dig him but when he says to me
that
you know 60 of people in new york city
believe in you know they want gun
control and i have to convince them to
vote for me otherwise i can't do
anything my attitude is like you know
all you're really telling me is that
you're doing the same thing to me
that you're telling me here's the idea
to to solve the problems but you're
probably just trying to tell me what i
want to hear so that i vote for you
right
that's the reality the reality is where
it and it's tricky i know what you're
talking about where do you start i have
a lot of friends who are um
anarcho-capitalists they are they they
believe in stateless society governed by
nothing but non-aggressions principle
and i understand the the reasoning for
it all and i could live in a world like
that any any any utopian vision like
that exists so long as you have a
homogenized culture communism would work
really really well if everyone agreed
communism was the best system the only
problem is at scale
you can't achieve that so the communists
start killing people and mass who oppose
their control humans are not
like they just line up like lemmings the
same thing is true for the
non-aggression principle utopian
fair capitalist society
yes someone's going to seek to exploit
it and destroy it and then it'll be
conflict right so it's hard to ever get
to those ends and that's why i always
said with them i understand when you're
coming from because they'll ask me frank
why do why do you still vote why do you
still believe in even in minarchism why
do you believe in the constitution it
always ends up i said well well here's
the thing uh
here's we'll have a chance to try out
the stateless society thing if there is
a there's a 95 of the world is just
destroyed by an asteroid or a virus or
whatever the hell else like it's the
stand we'll you'll have a shot you'll
have a shot to check out your stateless
society other than that there's only one
way you can even try
try
harkening back to what we were talking
about with larry sharp there's only one
way you can even try is to start
nudging the needle you have to start
walking back eventually you'll walk
through the the threshold of the
constitution again thomas jefferson
thought that the the the constitution as
a nucleus uh the the that's actually the
centrist position uh traditionally
american
centrist position it's the constitution
thomas jefferson and some others
actually thought that we would be able
to evolve intellectually to even go away
with less
less than the constitution we'd be able
to wanted a monarchy in the united
states well yeah there's that i think we
do we don't really need a house of
representatives because we can represent
ourselves we have the power and the
technology to have our own voices heard
and our own beliefs you know
put out there for like a reddit style up
vote down vote system except direct
democracy doesn't work no it'd be more
of a rep well that's why i talk about
like um
having like uh smart contracts that do
the votes for us so like
you'd still have a check there so like
our 700 000 people would vote yes or no
on a thing and then it would go to their
little smart contract which would say y
or n depending if it was a yes or no
then there'd be 430 other smart
contracts all going off so it's not i
not the whole mob can't get anything
done i like the attempt i mean but it
doesn't solve for the same problem that
is nancy pelosi and aoc will win no
matter what no matter how stupid
or corrupt they are mob mentality is
always dangerous
so that issue isn't solved by your
proposal no i don't think we can solve
mob mentality so the issue is what you
proposed presents us with the exact same
problem potentially worse a bun the
majority will just vote for whatever
nonsense they think from the media
regardless of if it's true or not
i i'll tell you this too i'll tell you
this
it's not even it's not even about that
well here's what will happen if we do a
direct representat
direct representative vote where it's
like you're in new york's 14 and say say
new york 14 cast your vote on h.r you
know 1781 in the federal government then
aoc comes out and she does her tour and
tells everyone vote yes vote yes vote
yes and they go whatever you say aoc so
it's the exact same system you mean if
she's not in in congress if if you get
rid of congress and say everyone say
there's no house for the senate still
you will end up with evangelists like
aoc in the exact same position yeah and
she would hold meetings seth rogen or
you know whoever just mouthpieces of
people using mass media and then you'd
end up with the exact same issue
either we vote for them or vote for the
issues they want they'll get what they
want well if you were able to make some
kind of correction a course correction
to how
we we are able to
operate on a federal level and the state
level which is completely divest from
the federal leviathan that is
almost wholly um illegitimate but on the
state level here's the thing that
usually happens you look at california
you look at vermont you have these
places that are cobalt blue they still
can't pass universal health care because
once you relegate something to the
states even the most progressive commie
nut is going to have to sit down and say
we don't have the money for this
you know when you're able to steal for
40 from 49 other states
i mean you can do and and and it's not
even that as much as it is charging it
to the central bank yeah it's such a
oh man that's the real thing here the
most the most progressive person becomes
conservative when you localize decision
making and you'll actually gain you gain
inroads with other people who who want
to fix problems nobody wants to see um
the older americans younger americans
you know being left out in the cold when
it comes to um
medicare or anything or medicine and
healthcare or anything like that it's
just that we've dehumanized each other
and and we're fighting over the same
three levers on on a federal level it's
not supposed to be that way and and the
dehumanization is the worst part about
all this i i think it doesn't always get
more conservative as you go more local
because like i don't know if you're
familiar shae's rebellion right after
the union was formed basically right
after the revolution um the i think was
in massachusetts they needed to pay back
debt foreign debt and they needed hard
currency which is which is metal they're
a soft currency which is like barter
that will sell you send you corn but
they told their farmers who are all
these returning war vets from the
revolutionary war and that had missed
like three seasons of harvest we need
your hard currency to pay back the
farmers like we don't have hard currency
we don't have metal they're like well we
need it so give it to us or we're going
to throw you in jail so the the the
state government started throwing their
own farmers in jail the farmers went to
the courthouse and rebelled they threw
more people in jail and that's when the
federal government realized we need we
need like an overprotection to make sure
that states don't abuse their own people
yeah like some kind of banking system at
the federal level that would help
regulate when these currency
fluctuations like a federal like like a
reserve of some sort more like a
national guard
that can stop rogue states from abusing
their own populace or stop chase
rebellion from ever happening again
um they they
they actually pardoned a lot it was john
hancock he pardoned a lot of those
people which is something i think they
should do it's kind of like a j6 thing
like they went to the courthouse to
protest and then they got thrown in and
hancock was like yeah it's done we're
moving on as a union let them out
well uh when
this is your point is more more on the
level of money or on the level of
protest if you get rid of a federal
government that a state government can
still go rogue still become like
totalitarian so oh sure they can they
can right now and like ex yeah yeah but
at least we have like federal
a federal guard to protect like crazy
localities
that's not even uh
it would really be uh i don't know
i don't know you're talking about like
if connecticut went to war with rhode
island if connecticut started throwing
people in gas chambers oh well this is
just crazy yeah that would be an extreme
example
but over what though uh money say people
were not paying debts in massachusetts
and they started imprisoning their
people in the american government that
happens right now if you don't pay you
don't pay your taxes you lose your house
you can i mean there's a lot of things
that happen uh it's it's horrible
you know i think we should do what i
think delaware should be forced to
become part of maryland and rhode island
should be forced to become part of
massachusetts delaware was was
originally part of
pennsylvania in fact after 76 when
everybody was declaring independence
there was 13
declarations in fact delaware declared
independence from pennsylvania as well
um delaware's too small so is rhode
island yeah unfortunately those states
you got to be merged back into the into
the larger state and then uh oh four
senators are gone how small is delaware
i feel like i drive through it in five
minutes whenever i come down here
because that's about right it's tiny
it's incredible go look at rhode island
yeah brother
city it was a plantation in the
constitution they're like rhode island
and the plantation next to it yeah it's
original name was they have one
representative
and now they get two senators and i love
it when the left is like
all of these empty red states get all
the centers and i'm like i kind of feel
like a state that that manages large
swaths of land is more entitled to that
than one city on the east coast
like providence is that rhode island is
basically a city and they get it's a
city that gets two senators and i'm just
like no
look you want to play this game of like
red states don't deserve senators or
whatever then i'll play the game too a
single city like wilmington they get a
cent they get two senators nah sorry
guys oh delaware's nine 1982 square
miles
96 miles long from somewhere wow that's
that's north of south south east west
like what like 10 i must have cut a
corner then yeah because well no when
you drive 20 when you drive through the
east coast like 20 yeah you're right 20
yeah based on the math okay so uh but
look at rhode island look up look up
rhode island
there are people who own ranches in like
montana that are bigger than rhode
island
right
easily
it's hard to undo what's been done
that's the problem that's what's going
on how big's rhode island rhode island
what okay let me this here
10 feet yeah this is it's a 58 foot
termite i don't know what i'm reading
what the exactly got to be
all right i'll pull this up thanks
road island jeez it's small what is it
oh i'm just looking at it neither a road
or an island yeah disgusting
square miles 48 miles by 48 by 37 that's
it
1 214 square miles that's a parking lot
that's a parking lot and they get two
senators
it's it's uh the name of it is the
colony of rhode island and providence
plantations
you see and that's fine again you say oh
well there's nobody in wyoming why do
they have you know blah blah blah and
why can they be a part of a thing that
stops us from achieving one thing or
another the only people the only people
who talk like that are these crazy
statists that want to do things that are
just not in the mandate not in the
charter for the federal government
that's just it it's
that's just it doesn't matter how much
farmland there is over the heart of
america uh los angeles and california do
whatever the hell you want
is it like a per capita uh maybe we
could do our representatives more based
on per capita than total population
because like when you have a thousand
people all stacked on top of each other
it's not really as cool as a thousand
people over like a 60 square mile radius
what do you mean that's what we do with
representatives yeah
per capita yes
so you get a rep for every 750 000
people you're talking about but i'm
saying that maybe the size of the area
where those 750 000 people live should
be taken into account when calculating
the amount of representatives so it's
like a bigger space of 700 000 people is
a little bit more inclusive than a small
space with 700 000 people those people
are more manipulable
they have more group think i guess and i
think the issue is if the power goes out
for instance like rhode island is a
single city basically
like i say that essentially
but you know there's more than just
providence but it's still like
you look at new york and how different
it is from new york city up to to
upstate and all the other cities in the
in the rural areas
you look at rhode island it's just like
i i to be honest
alexandria ocasio-cortez's district i
think it's like the 17th or the 14th i
think i think i'm the 17th um the 14th i
got my own problems but the the 14th
there's like there's close to 750 000
people there
now
the constitution again we're talking
about that a lot tonight thirty thousand
one representative per thirty thousand
there should be i mean you you do there
should be 20 20 reps in her i'm sorry 25
about 25 reps coming from her district
yeah i mean think about the absurdity of
thinking that she that p brain
represents the interests of over 700 000
people and i'll tell you something else
in that district i mean in that clump of
that that population right there it's
not going to be all democrat
if every single republican in her
district voted the republican would win
dude imagine if i had to represent you
guys if i had to go somewhere and
represent tim sheamus and you like i i
i can't what would i say like
yeah well i think that
frank thinks this and tim thinks this
and like i can't represent someone else
i can't do it i can only represent
myself in the general election aoc got
152
661 votes
the uh republican
slash cons the r slash conservative
party got 58 440.
and then the uh write-in republican zero
amazing
and uh he didn't even vote for himself
like guys or not geez what a joke out of
700 000 people
25
are republican it's a d plus 25.
so that means you would have what is
that what does that give you 210 000
republicans if every single republican
in aoc's district voted it would have
defeated aoc
they don't vote at all
and the republicans won't go in and even
bother with trying to get people to vote
because they're getting paid baby they
got to make some money for them
i should stop and say
it's not fair to say it's 25 republican
because it's probably like 18 or 19
republican and then you've got other
political parties in there as well it's
not anymore it shouldn't be a career man
i'm just so fed up with career
politicians that it's even thought of
that that's a career opportunity or
option it's insane it's no public
servant yeah no salaries but then only
rich people could do it no salaries but
you are allowed to do insider trading
you could pay the bills of the people
like all the travel all the lodging only
rich people would do it then no no oh
because you got to pay for their time
off work i mean because people have to
leave work to go do it so we compensate
them and then
this is these are the tough the tough
challenges i think it's really simple
frank i think what we do is as soon as
you get elected
no matter which so you're in congress
you get four years guaranteed you're in
the senate you get six years guaranteed
the president let's say
let's say you get i'm down two terms i'm
down for one term of six years with the
president all right let's say that once
you're done
you get shipped off to the island never
to be seen again there's no technology
there's no electricity we just the
helicopter flies over and they just push
you out of the parachute that's it and
that's it like in chile thank you for
serving no no you have a parachute like
oh okay the point is go live on the
island far away greenland you you get
forced to go live in greenland you can't
live here anymore then the only only
people no it still wouldn't work i know
it's a funny joke but then what would
happen is rich people would be like if
you do it i will give you a family five
million dollars and they'll be like i'll
do anything for my family and then they
they do what they're told and they get
ejected you need an episode of blacklist
denmark is an interesting idea
denmarque is where people get congress
duty
so it's like you go to the mailbox and
you got like a certified letter and it's
like or the mail person comes up i have
a certified letter can you sign for it
you sign for it it's like congress doing
you go ugh
uh i gotta go to dc honey i have
congress duty i guess and then you go
down and then there's an adversarial you
know attempt like you know some two
politicians will then be like how do you
feel about this how do you feel about
that and they're like okay we agree with
this guy and then you get approved for
congress duty and you serve for a few
months in dc and they're like here the
bills we're passing here the bills we're
writing
that's denmark okay
here's the thing with the autumn timber
so like
so i think you get like you do now but
now exactly
and then when you come home your
neighbors are going to be looking at you
like what did you do so
here's why i don't think we should do
something like that because
people are going to be going in there
completely disinterested not wanting to
be there making stupid decisions as a
result i mean we can only have that for
jury duty when you're deciding whether
or not someone committed a murder and
you know whether they're going to go to
jail for the rest of their lives not not
not for anything else
a jury no i mean i'm making fun of the
whole idea like with jury duty um the
fact that like jury duty is something
people don't want to do i remember my
dad telling this story he got selected
for jury duty back in the 80s
and
one of the people he this guy was like
look i have a business to run i don't
want to do this so he wore an american
flag tie he's like there's no way
they're going to pick me to be on this
and they didn't because he had an
american flag really yeah it's like a
bias thing it's like oh this guy's
conservative um
there was another lady
that was
they're asking him questions and there's
this old lady they know nothing about
the case at this point or what case
they're being selected for and they ask
her do you believe in the death penalty
and she goes yes and i think he should
get it
[Laughter]
so they're like you can leave me they're
like yeah across the board yeah you
should get it across whoever it is they
deserve it yeah and then it's like ma'am
do you know who the defendant is no and
then they look over it's like an
identical little old lady
frank i thought you were right on the
president six years and then he's out or
she's out because the whole wasting two
years running for reelection insane it's
insane it's insane i mean i i i think
about what we got from what we got out
of the the trump uh the trump first term
there
um so much of it was obviously he was
learning the ropes uh and he was he was
learning just how bad it was around him
including his own staff he was
surrounded by sharks but uh let's say
that he had everything together too many
people play it timid in that first term
because they just want to get to the
second one and then maybe let their hair
down a little bit i'd rather just see
who a person is let them get to work let
them fight their battles and uh and and
go for i mean i'm going to be against 90
of the things that they propose anyway
but i i would much rather stop with the
uh the pussyfooting what if what if we
just did this here's an idea what if we
had like a group of individuals who
really believed in this country
and it was a private organization that
you could enter in by swearing an oath
to it and then they would just choose
among their ranks who the chairman
should be who will rule
the country and it would be like a
political party and then they can uh
have their ideology as as like the name
of their party oh yes of the country so
like you know and then uh you have to
swear allegiance and then that you know
what else they could do they could put
that party in every corporation as they
answer to them and that ensures loyalty
to the centralized build community yeah
that's right community build community
and we could we could call it like a
community communism oh community
how about we we can call it freemasonry
as well
yes yes but but people don't understand
communism so we should just simplify the
the vernacular by saying com no no no no
here's how he said we'll do a little
slogan so people feel like they're like
you like communism instead of communism
we our party
when they select the senators is that
like a little communist dictatorship i
think the states should select the
senators and i think the 17th amendment
is a mistake i remember reading
something from ben sasse about that and
i was like what and then i was like he's
right
people don't care about their state
elections anymore because everything's
federal and then you get these these
politicians were like i'm running for
congress and if you vote for me i'll
clean up this town and it's like bro
state level politicians clear the town
you go to dc you go to dc and talk about
bombing kids the people we got to vote
for here to clean up the city are the
people who are going to represent the
city but people don't get that anymore
so the way it used to be you'd vote for
your state representative then they
would go and vote on who would represent
the state to the federal government that
made sense then they were like yeah
let's do popular vote and now it's a
bunch of idiots voting voting for a
bunch of other right because their
representatives would send their buddies
to the senate and then this their
buddies in the senate would do them a
favor when they proposed a law and
passed their life and it's no better now
so the amendment didn't fix any of the
corruption problems they were like let's
have the people the problem is the
popularity contest and that they the
term they don't have term limits because
you shouldn't be able to vote a popular
senator back yeah i don't think yeah it
should be something like that even four
there's so many of us now that want to
participate that giving someone six
freaking years you're going to be in
your 30s by the time that's the best
part ian if you really want to
participate what you can do i mean it
could be flipped like a switch at this
point because it's on the books i mean
we've gone through at least 120 years of
really bad
bad habits being instilled as american
tradition at this point but if you
really wanted to get involved locally if
you got onto your local city council
your town council you want to become
mayor you become sheriff
you can turn things around in your state
so much quicker than you can ever try to
even we shouldn't even be paying
attention to the federal government if
we all refocus on local elections and
what they're doing what people are
proposing and and really hammer down on
that i people have never been this
activated and uh and awake to what's
going on if they can just be refocused
locally
this whole thing could fall apart and it
would literally be like defeating freddy
krueger you just look you just say i
don't believe in you i mean it's all
illegitimate
it's all illegitimate i think you know
as i often talk about civil war and
conflict
i think that that may end up happening
but i do think that we are still winning
and uh i'll break that down for you what
that means
people are waking up more and more
people every single day decentralized
information is winning the ratings are
collapsing for the mainstream networks
they're losing trust
channels like ours are doing better and
better and other networks are growing
people are using decentralized sources
of information we are winning
but there is an effective internal
thucydides trap that will occur then
when the growing culture
is seeking to supplant the existing one
then you will likely end up with some
kind of conflict so we have a culture
war right now you have the establishment
which is completely in line with woke
corporations and the woke activists in
antifa but it feels like they're losing
they're becoming increasingly unhinged
because of it like firebombing pregnancy
centers because they lost roe v wade
the freedom the libertarian the
decentralized the roe v wade decision
was ultimately a libertarian movement
the federal government saying we hereby
rescind our authority over the states on
this matter
and that is a movement towards
decentralization the left wanted the
federal government to assert its
authority to grant them what they wanted
nationwide
so ultimately i think
freedom and liberty are going to start
winning power is being rescinded but the
establishment is losing power but
they're going to thrash and get violent
before the end comes i was thinking like
what would the the founding fathers like
what would jefferson and ben franklin do
right now if they came here and i was
like guys what what do we do like or
george washington they'd be like dude
the corporations are way too powerful
i think we need to
i think they i think they shoot
themselves in the head well put
themselves out of their misery no they'd
be excited they'd be like dude you got
electricity still but we we need to
attach large cylindrical magnets to the
bodies of the founding fathers corpses
because they're spinning in their graves
so fast it would generate tons of free
energy ben franklin would be interested
i think that i think that a lot of a lot
more people than we think would come to
a rally and call if like if we had
george washington come back
like the mensch that he was and he was
just like yo let's we we've got we've
got things to do i think that a lot more
people would rally to that call than we
think um but
but they would also face real danger i
mean first of all they would be
reincarnated slave owners
so the people would be like finally we
have one you know they're not just
chasing ghosts
the founding fathers would come back and
be like i don't like any of this and
they would think everyone was crazy yeah
too much corporations in the federal
government they gotta you gotta unwind
the the corporate power like when did
corporations become people well that was
was that glass not glass-steagall no it
was mitt romney he declared it he said
corporations are people my friend and
then instantly corporations were
corporate law's little nuts dude but
speaking of well there's 101 year old
ex-nazi that was sentenced to five years
in prison for being a prisoner
all right well let's go to super chats
my friends if you have not already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and share the
show with your friends it's the best way
to help out head over to timcast.com
become a member to help support our work
we're hiring more journalists we are
expanding if you haven't checked out the
cast castle vlog we've got a couple
really awesome special guests coming up
in the next few episodes very famous and
individuals who are uh joining us in our
silly gags and skits it's gonna be a lot
of fun
and uh don't forget to smash that like
button we're gonna have a members only
show coming up for you at 11 pm at
timcast.com check it out let's read what
we got
no
quesada says tim i wouldn't consider the
far left to be pro-gun aoc and the squad
are pretty anti-gun but they're like
they're leftist and not and and and
somewhat far left but the actual
socialist they have like the socialist
rifle association socialists and like
the real revolutionary far left are
pro-gun
until they gain control and then they
want to take your guns away right so
it's not the same as how we're pro-gun
we're like people should be allowed
right
all right
what is this
meta tax as timpool wakes up to a big
bowl of civil war o's oh civil war
like cheerios have you ever just how
often have you discussed how you see
that even playing out in um
800 times okay so then because i i talk
about it as well too it's it's not it
would never be anything like what we did
before i mean we should be pretty
familiar with the the scenario because
we
these are the kind of conflicts that the
cia used to drum up in africa and middle
east operation gladio type of stuff um
but like what do you what do you think
is most this is how it would play out
uh oh i don't know i think
there's a whole bunch of different
scenarios one of one of them is uh we're
already seeing it states
announcing they do not recognize the
authority of the federal government
um
so we have immigration laws california
says we don't care it's not outright
nullification it is
you know sanctuary states nullification
would be california saying we will
oppose the federal government trying to
enforce these things right now they're
just kind of saying we won't assist you
but we will actively as a state allow
the defiance of federal law so we're
halfway there
that happens enough times texas says we
do not see california's votes as
legitimate because they're allowing
non-citizens into the country who then
affect congress and the electoral vote
count
so when that happens
then what do you do
i don't know i to tell you i don't know
i expect i speculated on it a lot and i
think uh just because we're in the u.s i
mean
waco ruby ridge that would be pretty
much what we'd be looking at central
power doesn't care about killing anybody
all right let's read some more we got
raymond g stanley jr says tim i had an
aunt who had down syndrome she was a
beautiful soul she was kind always full
of smiles she was the glue of my
mother's side these people want her to
have never felt love or give freely her
love her her own love to us they are so
much more than i've ever imagined rip
and judy and this is in reference to
i was doing a segment earlier about um
the democrats funding the quote unquote
far right
and i read a story about anna navarro
saying i know exactly why i needed
abortion because i have a 57 year old
brother who's got the mentality of a
one-year-old and i've got a i've got a
family member who's got down syndrome
and i got another family member and i
was just like so you're basically saying
to kill these people what and here's the
point i made
without getting into great detail
some people that i've known since i was
very young were gonna get married and
then the guy's fiance got to a car
accident got a traumatic brain injury
and then was
like paralyzed uh partially paralyzed
traumatic brain injury unable to live
without assistance if you were to come
to me and say this person was born
developmentally disabled so we should
have aborted them my question is what
would you say to someone who is 20 years
old and get smacked in the head with a
baseball bat and now is in a wheelchair
should they be killed on the spot should
they not be alive it's a psychotic
argument and it's exactly why i'm sick
to my stomach because there's people
like anna navarro saying this
she's not saying anything anything
meaningful she's saying i will say
whatever it takes to support the
pro-choice side or the pro-abortion side
and then i'm like look i'm i'm even you
know old-school pro-choice but if you
come as a democrat and say
my sis
they're talking about how there's down
syndrome relative people who live full
meaningful lives and have families in
love should have been
should never have been allowed to have
been alive i'm like you're you're a
psychopath you're a fascist you're
you're a nut job ultimately i mean to
have that kind of mentality you really
do need to view human beings as things
they're not their own individual person
who matters as an end in and of
themselves they're a thing and that
thing makes me feel uncomfortable so we
should just get rid of it or it
shouldn't even have been there in the
first place i just i just i just can't
believe
that
more than once and navarro on cnn came
out and said i have disabled family
members therefore we should have
abortion to kill them i know it harkens
to when we were living in tribes and
desperation when like a sick person
would hold the tribe back and maybe cost
its lives like if if you can't move if
you can't hunt because somebody has a
gimpy leg then you've gotta do something
with that that that hunter that can't
hunt anymore and you a lot of times they
would just kill them off no they
wouldn't oh back in the day if you had
like a deformed child they would kill it
immediately humans are social beings who
survive because we take care of those
who are injured that's a fact but i'm
not just talking about injury i'm
talking about there were certainly some
cultures like sure the spartans they
would put the babies in the woods or
whatever and they would be like but the
on average
humanity survived by taking care of each
other that's why we are socially driven
beings because a human who is left out
to their own devices
tended to die and the humans who tended
to be social and stay within the tribe
tended to live because we protected each
other the concept of insurance emerged
because when we started building our own
dwellings if mine fell down
everyone else would come and help me
rebuild it it was just a pact
we wouldn't just be like oh you lost
your house now you're dead you're a drag
on the society no we we helped them when
someone's leg was broken we made sure
they survived that's reality
that well i would say with this um
i know you're you're really focusing on
the horror of what anna navarro has said
more than once now and i if you want a
little bit more perspective as to
the um the mindset from which this was
born
have you covered at all what was going
what's going on with the euthanasia
programs in canada no
this is incredible i think it's called
the maid program or something maid
something but the euthanasia programs in
canada uh the assisted suicide programs
they continue to expand to the point
where it's they're making it available
and they're starting to suggest this for
people who aren't even terminally ill
people who are uh people who are you
know in in dire financial straits
quality of life when it comes to anxiety
anything like that and and it's it's
it's like that it's that bad and worse
so you go check that out and when i'm
reading this and covering it as these
articles come out from time to time i
say to myself
of course they're so flippant about
human life here in the united states for
the unborn
out of sight out of mind if they're
doing this with people who have been on
the earth for decades already
i i i
a child that they have never seen
before means nothing to them i should
reiterate i'm not talking about it like
someone that loses a leg in in that
you're like you would help them but like
if a baby's born with no limbs and it's
you only have a certain amount of food
in the tribe to go around and everyone
works to help the tribe survive but this
one can't then they would make
harsh
necessary choices about who to who to
feed i mean it's well that depends very
much too on the tribe and the
civilization
we live in a place where we take healthy
people and put them on an altar and like
lop their heads off
but in we live in a society of luxury
where we still kill people who we have
determined to be inconvenient and there
have been societies much poorer than
ours who cared for those even when they
were difficult yeah because of our
luxury we really don't need to kill them
as much well that's because the numbers
no one does which is why it's even worse
when navarro is like these people
shouldn't be alive well let's let's read
some more super chat sorry move on we
got
ander webb says heads up the california
ag just leaked the addresses of every
registered firearm owner in the state
what
wow
john josh froman says you absolutely are
allowed to brew your own wine you can
make one of almost anything it's a fun
hobby and lots of people enjoy however
you can't make your own whiskey and so
i'm actually really bitter about that
which is why i don't want to see people
happy making their own wine
that's why that's why i wanted to stop
tim
wine wine we have wine berries so cool
so they're like raspberries and but
they're they're a little harder
you know
than like raspberries kind of mushy and
soft and break apart these ones are a
little little strawberry but they'd be
really good dried like dehydrated wine
oh yeah super good welcome to the
trailer starting to blossom i was
walking down the driveway and i grabbed
a couple pop them right on your mouth
the funny thing is there are these
little bugs that sometimes live in them
oh great and they're like they're
actually really they're like yellow and
they're little they're actually really
cute they have little arms and they'll
start waving at you and eat them
is actually controlled by the bugs
that's why he wears the beanie so you
can't see there's a bunch of them
but uh you get a little extra protein in
your in your wine you know we need to
get those long we try to get babies
oh we found a turtle yesterday
nice yeah a little box turtle but uh you
can't keep them as pets they don't they
don't survive well so we just had to it
was he was under one of them
one under one of the skate ramps almost
got crushed i was worried so we took him
out and we put them in the woods there's
a bigger one apparently they're
everywhere we got turtles everywhere
chinese box turtles i have no idea
oh we got chinese stink bugs everywhere
yeah those things are awful you've seen
them special thanks to china you got
them a frank new york i we do have stink
bugs in your i don't know if they're
chinese though it's that brown
marmaladed one yeah you'll know them and
they're everywhere it's like it's in a
basic species they came like the 90s
into pennsylvania they arrived i think
it was they were planted there by
something did you guys have any of that
that weird infestation oh yeah
spotted fly yeah those are weird yup
it's fun to go out and smush them
because they're like you got to kill
them they're invading all right let's
see we got here
let's see super arrow says i'm a home
brewer from ohio ever since you first
mentioned the wine berries i thought it
would be interesting to make wine from
them maybe we could make a tim cass
special one and do a segment on it how
do so here's a funny thing you're
driving down the road outside you know
western western maryland or whatever
west virginia
i watch people pull their carve onto the
shoulder and grab a handful of wine
berries and get back in their car no
joke because they're literally
everywhere you turn out of the highway
out here and you can you can fill up
probably like
a 10 gallon bag in a few minutes
i'm exaggerating but maybe like a half
an hour you're gonna fill up you know a
huge bag that's like do you ever have
you ever been to a acadia park in maine
oh it's beautiful and the blueberries
everywhere oh wow people get out on the
side of the mountain and they're just
bags of blueberries we got pawpaw in
october and september october too you
know pawpaw yes yeah
i was i thought there was going to be
very very little because we couldn't see
any and then i was mistaken because then
end of september
end of september you walk into the woods
and you're getting hit in the head by
them as they fall and it's like take
five minutes and you've got like 50 paw
paw and i'm like i don't even know what
we're going to do with it it's delicious
by the way ian made a bread
yeah it's good all right
incompetent hands uh 30 says huge fan of
quite frankly and tim cass so this is
awesome tim did you ever get a haircut
from a russian at the palisades center
if so did you feel cursed asking for a
friend i have no idea what that means
what is that i okay when i was going
when i went to the uh i went to the
palisades mall when i was 15 years old
we all went to super cuts and i'm
getting my hair cut and the guy this
russian guy is on top of me he's going
oh you know you're you're losing your
hair a little bit or something i said no
i'm not i'm not even losing my hair what
are you kidding me and so so so he's
telling me and and i'm i guess he must
have seen something
and uh and i started getting a little
bit agitated because i just wanted a
haircut and be left alone and he said
what you can't have everything and he
starts like i don't know it's trying
being very flippant about it so now i
get i get tormented about the russians i
just shave my head now it doesn't matter
i got theory about that they say it's
genetic passed down from the grandma
male pattern baldness i think it's the
temperature of the shower that you are
taught as a kid is the normal
temperature and if it's too hot it
singes the follicles
so
i just think that's not true well you
gotta if the water is too hot it'll
strip the oil out i don't think damage
no
and my your idea of hot could be
different than my idea of hot because i
i take lukewarm like
yeah so i'm like i have a hot a higher
than normal body temperature dude did
elon musk get implant hair implants
because he's like a full luscious head
of hair now also my grandfather had a
full head of hair whole life skips
generations yeah well it doesn't matter
to me uh my grandfather had no hair that
means it should skip and
it's meaningless it's all nonsense
from the mother's side right showers man
that's that's just not true yeah but
in japan
before the americans came in and
introduced a high fat diet they didn't
have male pattern baldness and now they
do huh yeah but let's read some more
super chats cause we got a good one
indeed kentoki says that's not ian
crossland that's chicken ian show us
your rock collection kitten toki if you
go over to chickencitylive.com there is
a new cartoon up we asked an artificial
intelligence to write a story about ian
chickens in the federal reserve and it
wrote us the synopsis of a story so we
animated it and it's actually really
really funny so uh chickencity.com it
just brings you to the youtube channel
and then you can see the video and it's
really funny ian is a chicken
and uh he's going to school and he gets
bullied someone's learning someone's
listening yeah it's a it's it's it's it
was a funny pretty funny yeah i remember
i typed in the ai i was like tell me a
story about these things and then when
it popped up i started laughing and i
sent it to kent our animator and then i
was like dude we should turn this into a
cartoon brilliant yeah
all right
let's see we got
bc says tim great to see frank on the
show you should get matt christensen and
blonde next absolutely they are both
welcome at any time always welcome yeah
we should reach out and see if they're
ever available to come on they do their
own show so you know
all right let's uh i like matt's a good
buddy of mine too
yeah yeah he's up in the middle of
nowhere though any i did their show
a number of times years ago and then it
just fell off they're great though
they're great yeah they're early
adopters of mines i've known them really
known of them for like a decade yeah all
right on it cody bridger says i am a
winemaker who has practiced around the
world and i'm currently in washington i
would love to help you with wineberry
wine
i'll i'll talk to the currency if
anyone's interested in how you actually
do that what do you do you just mash
them up put them in a cask and forget
about it is that how it works forget
about it forget about it and then come
back later you're like hey it's alcohol
one thing you do is forget about it all
right kodias veritas says hey tim i work
for a brewery and in the past week we
have seen grain prices go up 45 beer
shortages may be on the horizon and if
you think people are mad when there is
no food to eat it just wait till there's
no beer yo we we do these shipments
every quarter or so where we get like
hundreds of cans of beer we're about
overdue because people love it we get
like local brewery stuff well since i've
been here it hasn't been enough no
matter how much they order
we're out aren't we we need to get more
we've been out for a while we've been
out for a while yeah and james he's he's
fighting the habit so he didn't tell us
but um the price has been going up
ridiculously
so i believe i i guess i i um
people i haven't started
them no but that's i believe it
everything i mean all food's going to
get more expensive can you make beer
from
walnut trees
i don't know walnut trees
i feel like you can make
this out of everything i i've heard
people making really weird concoctions
and as long as you can ferment it
somehow dandelions i learned that for me
and then i started looking up and
appalachia dandelions are like a common
thing wait the actual flour the actual
flour when it's yellow you take it you
take the head off and you fry it you eat
it and it supposedly tastes like
mushrooms oh see i i okay well we
dandelions were brought here by the
pilgrims for medicinal uses and now
they're a weed everywhere my
grandparents used to send me and my
brother out into the uh the driveway to
pick the dandelion leaves to make salads
like it's a yeah it's a depression like
a depression uh measure now you eat the
heads though i didn't know about the
flowers the actual the actual leaves
though man they're a little bit bitter
but you toss them into a a salad bowl a
little bit of vinegar a little bit of
oil and your i got i got dandelion tea
because
it's so good it's the best you've ever
had
no joke it's detox it's like a vanilla
dandelion tea yeah
yeah it was amazing
all right let's grab some more super
chats
miguel lopez says thanks for having
frank on your podcast a lot of my
favorite peeps crossing over it confirms
i'm listening to the best of mines on
the net you know it
all right let's grab some more we got a
bunch of angry people insulting me
insulting me more yes nate says does
anyone remember the old bible man show
because tim describing that episode in
the orville makes me think of it they
went too woke and now they're slowly
going broke
yeah the orville used to have jokes in
it
the new season has no jokes in it it's
weird
that is weird i feel like seth
macfarlane just wanted to be captain
picard yeah 100
and so they were like the only way he
could do it is if they were like if you
do a comedy and he was like all right
we'll put jokes in it and now that he's
got a new deal on hulu it's called new
horizons and there's no jokes and it's
just really dry
i'm like it doesn't work you guys i
tried to watch kimmel the other night it
was chelsea hadler is the weekly host
and it was just oh democrat she's
immediately started talking about
politics like within like 10 10 words it
was politics yeah what is this even the
most important things she's done in the
last um 10 years she didn't even know
that it was good uh she had this guy on
from the department of energy right
around the time that stranger things
came out around 2018
whatever it was and he was talking about
he made it a mission that they dabble in
other parallel universes and stuff and
of course she made some whoa trippy lsd
comment about it like that this is a
gold mine ask him real questions it's
the best thing she ever did now she just
slurs the rest of the way all right
phil nyes has long time girlfriend just
got her tubes tied due to the roe v wade
decision so now i'm single she's in a
cult and everyone seems blind to it
i'm sorry to hear that man but good for
you not of that it's like iuds exist
terrible you know whatever man
all right let's see we got
david toronto says
the protest didn't work they overturned
roe v wade they overturned the guns they
overturned the coach praying that's
right
the craziest thing is how they lie about
the main ruling and the coach ruling i'm
seeing memes pop up on facebook where
they're like the supreme court has just
ruled that uh school officials can lead
children in prayer
now it's time to bring in the satanism
blah blah blah i'm like no they didn't
they ruled that a single person minding
their own business can pray
while they're at work
not understand
how how was that ever not possible
anyway dude said he wanted to pray at
the 50-yard line or something they said
hey you can't do that he said okay i'll
stop praying and said no you're fired
anyway and then he went okay well i'm
suing you the dude actually was like i
will stop doing this but they fired him
anyway
the court said you can't tell someone
not to pray that's insane especially
since he wasn't leading children in the
people yeah it was just personally but
because he was on the 50-yard line it
was like a public display it was after
the game yeah his mistake you know if he
led children through a transition or
something right like that would be
completely fine groomed them in some way
that would be fine but praying oh my
goodness heavens forbid it's an
important one
mahil says when will tim get to do the
bill gates voice on a freedom tune
oh my gosh that's that's a good question
we wrote well we wrote one that would
never be allowed on youtube i should say
you pitched an idea to me that would
never ever be allowed on youtube but did
i we could yeah the one where he's got
the app on his phone oh yeah that was so
good we could maybe maybe maybe we'll
make that for like the freedom tunes
behind the paywall should we just tell
the joke no because you'll get booted
off you like it's they'll never allow it
i don't even think we can say it really
i don't even think we can say it no no i
really don't i think they they would
nuke this it's really good too it's
pretty it would be it would be a really
great skit it's like three minutes long
don't you don't think we'll make it you
know for activity off platform too it's
a it's not not really no patreon that
did that no but
the gag is basically about bill gates
it's about uh cell phones it's about
cell technology it's about vaccines he's
using yeah yeah well
people are going to freedomtunes.com and
signing up right now yeah yeah go over
to freedoms.com become a member we can
record it afterwards and just do it yeah
yeah we should work on it it's a good
bit it is a really good bit it is really
yeah it's good rule of threes all right
well now you spoiled it by telling them
the rule of threes is involved
okay okay more times
decide thought says i saw that orville
episode i think of it backwards wasn't
about trump winning but about the
deceptive destructive and divisive
nature of the democrats and how they
intentionally make peace seem evil
maybe but it was like
the moderate candidate who was supposed
to win lost because of influence
campaigns then then the polling was
showing that this motto was going to win
and then when the populist wins
literally executes the moderate
like you watch them do it they're like
what have you done and then she's like
now i will kill all of you it's like
okay
then they they won't make our planet
great again the planet is is a religious
zealous planet that worship is there's
their their deity avis they have the
they have their own bible
and they're like we are the pure and
like we are the chosen people so we
can't allow these other societies in
krill first and it's like okay make
ava's great again i was like i was a
little on the nose no i think it's yeah
the female who is leading the uh her
name is talia and she talks like this
i am the greatest i am the greatest i
will say this not a big fan of i've only
seen a few episodes but for all of its
flaws it is much more similar to star
trek than anything being produced i know
the name of star trek right now
it's funny and sad yeah
all right
what do we got yet
the bros durham says the seven cities
area in virginia is bigger than rhode
island wow
that's right
alexander nelson says here is how we
take care of congressional salaries they
make the medium the the medium you mean
median wage of the state district
they're representing this will cause
politicians to actually have those they
represent best interests in mind i
disagree i think it'll mean only rich
people run
uh the median how can you afford a
residence in dc
there's members of congress who sleep in
their offices on the floor and then they
get yelled at because you're not allowed
to do it
because
they can't afford to pay rent in their
hometown and in dc because dc is
insanely expensive
yup
so it all work that's why that's why
they're all rich because only rich
people can do it the nation they should
uh make a dorm a dormitory for uh yeah
congressional dormitory oh yeah a murray
is a very very interesting argument it's
very very complicated it says government
doesn't and never will work
solid compelling nailed it compelling
argument
it's concise sev uh sever slate says
service guarantees citizenship
i like that idea i like that
all right where are we at
the other net fife says instead of term
limits how about a website that has
every bill uh that that has every bill
voted on
a a
priestess of the bill uh and a list of
how each rep or senator voted with the
option for the congressman to comment on
their vote that exists it's uh i was a
bill tracker
and or i think on the issues too or just
the issues.com and it pulls up the bill
it shows you all of the votes green and
red yes and no and then you you can see
it's it's it's it's good
all right
well um
mail
mile francis says sheamus is so cute he
gives me hope that i'll meet a nice guy
my age who agrees with my values i'd ask
him out but i am on the west coast and
can't wait to leave love the freedom
tunes website god bless no thank you
that's very sweet i hope really hope you
find somebody oh we'll pray for you you
will
discern god's well say your prayers and
he'll show you everyone cooper herstein
says why is nobody talking about social
media companies doing zero
misinformation policing about roe being
overturned
because we all know there's a double
standard and these corporations are evil
so they don't care about what's true
they care about what's morally correct
people are unironically saying there was
a tweet i saw that had 250 000 likes and
it said
that this is going to make it illegal to
have uh a miscarried baby removed right
right right it's like that is not true
anywhere also it's like what do people
think america was like before 1973
women they think if women had
miscarriages they just died what's wrong
with that do you see that that comic
that cartoon someone made where it's the
american flag but the red stripes are
pregnant women dragging their bodies
moaning it's like
you saw it and then
and then the stars on the american flag
are hangars and i'm just like is this
what you think was like was going on in
1973
just imagine being imagine being that
that living in that headspace
that's the problem
these are people living in a headspace
that is just terminal and by the way in
case anyone tries to say otherwise i'll
just put this bit of information out
there uh bernard nathanson the founder
of narol admitted they literally made up
every single figure they gave to the
press about back alley abortions and the
death rate that resulted from them it's
all completely untrue it's all
completely untrue
all right let's grab one more here
heather coren says might be too late for
tim and frank but gentlemen taking saul
palmetto stops
follicle death but won't bring back
already lost hair you are welcome that's
silly i have a very simple solution
it's called the beanie you wear the
beanie and then you're not bald anymore
people don't know this frank's frank's
wearing a baseball cap hey problem
solved
and i only really wear if i only really
wear this when i'm on air because i
don't like the feeling of this the the
the head sweating and feeling it with
the uh the cans on but i don't know the
song
people don't get it i had a uh i used i
did a video today about the the
transgender skating thing and i showed a
video of myself from when i was 16 still
wearing the beanie 17 wearing the beanie
18 wearing the beanie like they don't
understand like it's it's just like a
thing i've always done so that's
actually his hair well it's stuck to my
head i can't get it off it's the same
thing with me though with this too i i
fell in love with fitted baseball caps
when i was in like third or fourth grade
and of course it's stupid to get a child
something that that that age because you
grow so quickly but around fifth sixth
grade my mother started getting me i i
wanted all of the major league baseball
hats i got the everything even the the
retired ones i want the old white socks
i wear the brooklyn dodgers hat a lot i
just love fitted baseball caps i always
have and uh and then you know
once
once college came out it was was done
and i realized that i was receding i
said oh whatever i share i shave my head
anyway so i'm just gonna keep shaving
and keep wearing hats
and uh that's it that being said we're
gonna go to the members only show so if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to timcast.com
become a member support our work and you
will get access to the exclusive segment
coming up at 11 p.m you can follow the
show at tim cast irl you can follow me
at timcast you can follow we're actually
posting now to facebook as well it's
facebook.com timcastnews where we're
gonna be putting up a whole bunch of
stuff and uh uh frank you wanna shout
anything out yeah i would really like to
for personally uh just thank you for
for i i never never really thought i'd
ever come on this show or whatever but i
i uh i'm so grateful for you to invite
me and i had a wonderful time meeting
you guys and the whole crew and uh
before i shout out my my channel and all
that i would like to personally
invite you all anytime you need to go to
new york for any reason come by the
studio be part of a show
i have a very cozy studio waiting for
you all to come by and be a guest but
quite frankly dot tv
i go live monday through friday 7 p.m uh
i know that tim goes live at 8 but i can
be a nice little pre-show for you host
of a nicely
talk show current events hidden history
human condition and the great beyond on
just saturday night while you guys were
uh at the uh the mines event and on in
your um
in your your uh your panels there i was
interviewing a man who uh who died on
the titanic in 1912. and he was
reincarnated so i got that that was my
saturday night you get to do fun stuff
like that with me and uh and thank you
that's it and also shout out to mike the
mailman
he listens to my show
but he's also a big fan of yours tim and
and he uh and he came to me once when
somebody sent in a a super chat about me
and he's really
excited i'm going to be on so shout out
to mike can you say hi to mike the
mailman hi mike the mailman there you go
mike
right on okay
i'm seamus coughlin of freedom tunes i
saw somebody sent in a super chat saying
that they missed debates with straw men
well i've got good news for you two of
uh the cartoons we got behind the
paywall are debates with strawman we're
making more of them
if y'all want to support me and what i
do go to freedomtunes.com become a
member you will get an extra video every
week
as well as behind the scenes content
thank you so much uh ian crossline ian
crossland.net you guys rock man i really
appreciate your criticism and your
feedback because it's some of the
realest stuff out there frank dude
thanks man thanks for coming to being so
positive and like just encouraging me to
become a sheriff oh you can do it and
anything and i would come down anytime
if i if i was asked back again i would
bring my my daughter um that would she
would love it she's almost two but she
would just love the chickens yeah this
place is awesome you let me know
beautiful man all right see you later
thanks so much for coming frank thank
you all for joining us on this wonderful
crossover episode hopefully we can do
more of this in the future i love having
people from new york city because it's
not that far away you guys can follow me
on minds.com and twitter at
sourpatchwords as well as
sourpatchlids.me
and if you want to see chicken ian go to
chickencitylive.com
we just put up the new cartoon and it's
actually i'm really impressed it's one
of the longer it's like over two minutes
it's funny it's ian as a chicken going
to school
and discussing the federal reserve
you'll get a good laugh out of it we'll
see you all over at timcast.com thanks
for hanging out
you